foreign
thank you to all that are attending
today and we're ready as the education
committee to go ahead with our public
hearings today we have one two three
four five hearings scheduled for
information for the committee
we were informed last night at least I
was when I left here around 5 30ish
that we have one bill that's an early
bill that was identified on the
information which we get from OLS as due
March 16th
well an early bill has to be out by Mar
February 16th which is today
and the bill is HB 623 and I spoke with
represent Myler regarding this this is
the
um Bill dealing with uh teacher loan
forgiveness
and
that bill is an important bill
uh however we have to have it out to
date we have to have it out today
and we have to make a decision today so
we will be cutting into our hearing
process when we get a short break
somewhere and looking at that bill
in the interim I've been asked that
everybody look at SB 140 which is a bill
which is in the Senate dealing with
recruitment of teachers
and that is a bipartisan bill
um and uh is something that could you
know come to us and we could build upon
that we've talked about that
it's unfortunate that that's that's
what's happened here
um but that's that's life
okay uh thank you Mr uh chair I I was
scheduled to meet with uh Mr Appleby on
Friday to kind of redo it and to do with
the bill what we were talking about so I
will be moving to retain that bill uh
when we get into executive session
and we've had quite a discussion on the
build even when it was introduced
regarding you know the criteria which
would qualify somebody for this uh the
payment plan how would the payment plan
looked like it would be an annual Affair
or would it be a sum total at the end or
however you want to do it so there there
is work that has to be done on this bill
but we do have a like bill on the other
side of the wall and we oftentimes do
this so that's something we will discuss
at that time
so right now we have uh in front of us
well one other Bill be looking at
um we have had some discussion regarding
the mental health instruction mental
health in in the classroom and all I'd
also ask you to look at SB
157 mental health education that's being
heard that's over in the uh Senate
education
it has bipartisan support 13 Senators
have signed on to that particular bill
so it's something that we may want to
look at as well
rather than having to go through and
modify something we have we may wait for
that that Senate bill that's just
something I would like you to look at so
that we you're all aware so two bills to
look at SB 140 that's the recruitment of
teachers in the Senate and SB 157 mental
health education in this that's also in
the Senate
okay going on today with HB 553 relative
School District information on Personnel
salaries
we uh are going to open up this hearing
evidently the prime sponsor is not here
so representative Belcher would you
please just go read the title introduce
the bill and then we'll take any
testimony that we may have on that bill
you look much like representative
cordelli
I'm not going there
good morning Mr chair honorable members
I am here to introduce House Bill 553
relative to school district information
on Personnel salaries
thank you very much thank you I expect
there's no questions from the committee
thank you
all right let's go on then to the cards
which we have here and we have Barrett
Christina of the school boards
Association
thank you chairman lad good morning
members of the committee bear Christina
from the school boards Association we
are opposed to the bill
um without getting to hear sort of the
the purpose of why this bill is being
introduced I'm going to just presume
that it relates to more openness and
transparency that's certainly a good
thing on hsba certainly does not oppose
our public bodies being more open and
transparent the challenge with the bill
is that
um excuse me
um I am not sure what they mean by all
position names and their annual salary
or hourly salary position names could be
let's just say your first grade teachers
but you may have five first grade
teachers
within a particular building each making
a different salary so the position names
if you're just saying first grade
teacher second grade teacher third grade
teacher you don't tie a salary to that
position you tie a salary to a person
the second aspect is that um the the
Public Employee Labor Relations Board
the pelrb the agency that hears disputes
between public employers and public
employees by law they're required to
post all the collective bargaining
agreements in the state online I know
there's always some lag time but there
are hundreds of of bargaining units if
not thousands of bargaining units across
the state so they have the database if
you owe the bank of collective
bargaining agreements on their statute
already and if you call your local
school district your superintendent or
board chair and say could I see the
collective bargaining agreement for our
teachers or could I see the collective
bargaining agreement for a pair of
professionals it's a public record they
they can they can send it out to you
um so um the other aspect too relative
to this bill we've heard a lot of
testimony this year and going back over
the last couple of years that we have a
lot of Staff in our school districts
that are not responsible for providing
direct Educational Services to students
whether that's excessive Administration
excessive paraprofessionals excessive
administrative assistants things of that
nature every time you ask a school
district to do something that's sort of
ministerial if you will that's
somebody's time and effort
um and you know yes we can find time and
effort to do that but you know a bill
here and a task there and a task here
and a task there that adds up to the
point where we have to hire another 0.5
FTE or I mean 0.5 you know admin
assistant to do these sort of clerical
things and administer and ministerial
aspects that don't necessarily relate
directly to the to the delivery of
educational services so for those
reasons I need SBA opposes the Bill
thank you very much are there questions
of school boards represent drying
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh this argument
comes up in our town meetings a lot of
times because the town employs the uh
the town office uh lists the salaries
down right down to the part-time police
officers and the people that plow the
roads but the school district does not
list the same way with teacher and
salary they refer us to a chart which we
you have to find it's cumbersome so if
this is public record what's the problem
with not just doing it the same way that
the town employs sure thank you for the
question
um representative and that may be a
practice in your town I'm not aware of
any I don't know the town statute so I
don't know if there's a law that
requires that
um public employees their salaries are
certainly public records I I don't
dispute that
um but I guess the other aspect would be
how often does this have to be updated I
would imagine in a school district like
Manchester you have paraprofessionals
coming and going all the time small
school districts you could probably do
it you don't have the the staff turnover
um but um you know larger districts when
you've got people coming and going
coming and going you have to update it
you know every year and so you know
could it be done possibly but then again
don't get frustrated with school boards
when you have to hire another 0.5 admin
to deal with sort of the the ministerial
work that would go behind it so like I
said in terms of the transparency we
don't oppose that aspect that's fine
it's just one more task for school
districts to have to comply with that
don't relate to the Direct Delivery of
educational services to kids
yes
thank you um in our town it's just an
annual report yeah so is would would
there be a problem if it was just like
an annual sure thank you for the
question um it's a good follow-up um no
I don't think there necessarily would be
um I guess one challenge is I don't know
how many Town employees you have I would
imagine your school district has
probably five times that I I'm just your
town your school is usually the biggest
employer in town generally depending on
on where you live
um but yeah it's sort of an annual
report I I think you know that would I
that would be more reasonable than it
being online and somebody having to
update it every time a new staff member
came on thank you thank you further
questions from the committee
represent board
thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
isn't at least possibly beneficial to
have this information out in the public
I speak in this regard as someone who
has defended the teachers as a union
president and
found that many people
make false comparisons such as teachers
only teach nine months out of the year
and act like they have the summer to fly
on the beach
and so this is a way of bringing forth
and reminding people that this person is
putting in a very full week yep and that
in fact if we want to retain them we
have to let them know that there's a
town next door or Upstate somewhere who
will hire them away because they're very
good and then part of what we have to do
is reminding the public yes there is a
cost to education okay thank you for the
question that that's a that's a great
take on it representative sort of
turning some of the arguments around if
you will
um yeah I mean that's certainly a
plausible reason for doing it and again
the transparency and openness we fully
support that but sort of the more policy
based reasons for why school district
will want to do this and show the
community that our teachers work hard
and the salary is fair but it may not be
we hear stories all the time that you
know Pittsfield was was the minor
leagues their teachers would work for
two or three years and then they'd come
to Concord or Cole Brown and make
fifteen thousand dollars a year more you
hear that story all the time and in many
communities so yeah that's a reasonable
a reasonable take representative
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking the question this
relates to outside Contracting does this
only apply to people who are hired by
the school district or maybe people
hired by an agency who come in with
special ed services or coming to serve
lunch they might work for a catering
service or whatever would they be
required to have their salaries listed
as well yeah thank you very much that's
a really good question representative um
our food service for example our is a
third party company that comes in and
then we have
um many special education therapists
like a a speech pathologist may not be
an employee of the district but works
for a third party vendor that comes in I
was interpreting this as meeting only
School District employees that's how I
was interpreting it thank you
are there further questions
thank you very much thank you uh we have
a card from um
Brian Hawkins uh and Nea New Hampshire
thank you Mr chairman uh
Ryan Hawkins and here New Hampshire I'm
not sure I have much more to add than
what uh Mr Christina mentioned uh the
the one asked the main aspect that I was
going to mention was that all of the
salary uh and benefit information on uh
uh the members that we represent are all
in collective bargaining agreements on
the pelrb website it is it is fairly
reliably uh updated
and there is a requirement to you know
submit those to the pelrb when they are
ratified so uh more I guess for
informational purposes than anything
else I'm happy to take any questions
any questions from the committee yes
represent luno thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you very much Mr Hawkins
um what type of information
um uh related to this might also be
available on the department of
education's website
I believe the department uh all I
believe the department also has
administrator information like soup for
superintendents and I'm not exactly sure
all of the positions but I believe that
those types of positions are available
and yep and follow up on that and those
would be positions that fall outside of
the collective bargaining agreement is
that's right all right thank you thank
you further questions yes representative
just just for just for the record are
you opposed to the bill uh I didn't sign
either way I was more informational as I
said I don't think it's necessary so I
guess somewhat opposed to it
um other than to say uh you know this is
this is public information and so
um and uh that is already articulated in
a in a uh on the in a collective
bargaining agreement that the community
votes on every year uh or uh every other
year and also on the plrb website
I'd like to be able to close down right
now so we could get into executing that
one bill we have to get out this morning
if we have a little bit of time we can
do it we can have a discussion here he
um I'll Stick Around Hawkins really did
not check off one or the other he's here
more to answer any questions but the
according to his pink sheet there was no
position he was taking it's more of a
technical support to this committee the
way he addressed it
now if I'm going to close this hearing
and get that other thing done which we
need to get done we can be asking
questions to him though when we get into
an exact session or something such as
that on this bill this is not an early
Bill we've got some time
but I will stick around too so
he's always around too okay that's it so
what I like to do is I'd like to close
this hearing right now I have no more
pink cards here and quickly enter into
an executive session uh on hb623
and I I love to represent Miler for a
recommendations thank you Mr chair I
would move to retain this bill as we
wait for the concomitant uh comparison
bill that comes over from the Senate
thank you is there a second
thank you very much representative
Cornell seconds the motion so we have a
motion on the table for retain on HB 623
made by represent Miler and second by
representative Cornell
discussion from uh Russell Miler no I
think you you yeah you positioned it
properly Mr chair thank you represent
Cornell further discussion from the
committee
ma'am clerk uh you have the
ready to go stuff
yeah take your time I'll fill that in
the afterwards don't okay be back from
saying no I'm not ready
okay uh the the motion is to retain 6 6
23 establishing a teacher candidate loan
forgiveness program
Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes sir oh you
are here okay
representative like us yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative I'm here
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner is not here
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes
18 years
thank you very much so we will close the
executive session we're back on track to
start the hearing process the point of
Interest or information for the
committee
this is the first Week Daytona is going
to happen it's NASCAR week and we used
to have representative Donaldson here
who was also a big Nascar fan but uh
so don't don't call me on on uh on a
Sunday
noted
okay so we'll take a about a minute
break here and then get right into
um the next bill which is HB 536
okay
Dylan nine o'clock in Traditions
I also have to see 436 get a hold of uh
I talked to
80 above I mean oh
we're going to go ahead now with the
HB 536
and representative Damon are you going
to be presenting the bill
thank you very much
this bill is uh an act relative to
Charter Public School joint legislative
oversight committee
okay thank you Mr chair and good morning
to the committee I can't resist since
you said representative Belcher look
like representative cordelli do I look
like representative Tanner
so House Bill 536 relative to the
chartered Public School joint
legislative
oh sorry and I am representative Damon
Sullivan County District 8 the towns of
Acworth Langdon Leinster Goshen
Washington Springfield Sunapee Croydon
and Claremont come visit
um this bill revises the structure and
duties of the chartered Public School
joint legislative oversight committee
I'm going to read from Linda's remarks
which I think give from representative
Tanner's remarks which give a good
history and statement of the concerns
the original concept of the chart of
schools first originated in the 1970s by
a Massachusetts educator by the name of
Ray Bud his idea was that groups of
teachers could set up contracts or
Charters with their local school board
to discover new approaches and ideas in
the field of Education Charter Schools
were developed as a way to discover new
approaches and ideas in the field of
Education
they were enacted into law in New
Hampshire in 1996 designed to be a type
of hybrid between public and non-public
schools they have open enrollment
operate independent of any school board
and are registered as non-profits
managed by a Board of Trustees
in New Hampshire Charter Schools receive
education funding from the state as we
know use fundraising and gifts they are
exempt from State statutes and rules
that apply to Public Schools non-public
schools local school boards or districts
except we're specifically specified in
statute
Charters are required to only have a 50
percent of their school teaching staff
be certified or have three years
teaching experience this is a major
difference from standard Public Schools
as part of the original Law in 1996 a
joint legislative oversight committee
was established and charged with an
annual report and review
and send the report to the State Board
of Education on Charter School approvals
this committee met many times in the
early years and delivered annual reports
reliably until 2009
when the term expired and that included
in 2007 a complete review of the New
Hampshire charter school program
and I quote in the recommendations from
that 2007 review
the state should invest urgently in the
necessary administrative capacity to
provide meaningful oversight of the
charter school program and fulfill
statutory requirements
there should be a full curriculum study
to determine the quality of the
curricula in use in charter schools and
their alignment with the New Hampshire
State Frameworks before reauthorization
there should be a school by school
review of the quality of classroom
instruction and the Assessments in use
both formative and summative
further the study recommended the
implementation of a formal
accountability process begun last year
so in 2006.
should be strengthened so as to develop
Clarity and consensus within and between
schools regarding the nature of the
required accountability plan measurable
goals should be developed by the schools
and demonstrated in their yearly report
end quote
the oversight committee was reinstated
in 2010
it has not met for the last six years
it had not filed or issued a report as
required in statute since 2011.
only four reports between 2013 and 2016.
charter schools are reviewed yearly for
fire safety and audited financially
the full review of curriculum staff Etc
is supposed to be on a five-year cycle
these reviews several in backlogs do a
two elapse of a charter school
coordinator position are being handled
through an outside vendor
we acknowledge that there are many
reasons standing committees fail to meet
this bill offers changes to help
facilitate a new committee composition
that will involve the chairs from the
House and Senate education committee or
their designees
in addition it adds a member from the
finance committee appointments from the
Senate President and Speaker of the
House it adds a non-voting
representative from the Department of
Education who specializes in charter
schools and allows for mileage
the oversight committee remains charged
to meet twice a year receive a report
from the state school board on the
charter school program and to deliver an
annual report with possible
recommendations for legislation
the committee will also be able to
receive requests from the state board as
listed in 194-b Colon 17.
and that reads the State Board shall
convene one or more working committees
to study and make recommendations
regarding the implementation and
effectiveness of Chartered Public
Schools the recommendations shall be
provided to the legislative oversight
committee as well as Section 8 the State
Board shall annually report to the Joint
legislative oversight committee
regarding approvals and denials for the
preceding 12 months and reasons for
approval or denial
I urge you to support this change that
will provide the spirit of the original
development of the charter school
program and once again provide
legislative oversight from elected
officials
thank you very much
welcome
um
representative are you willing to take
any questions on behalf of represent
Tanner or I can try and I will defer to
folks who know more if I can't be
helpful
I have a few other things okay revs
McDonald do you have a question thank
you Mr chair good morning representative
daming thank you for bringing this
forward on behalf of Representative
Tanner my only question is since no
charter schools are here to testify do
we have any general idea if they would
be supportive of this
I don't have any information to respond
to that I think it's interesting that
none of them are here to testify thank
you
for for the questions running from the
committee representative luno thank you
very much Mr chair
um and thank you very much
representative Damon for uh for
introducing that
um I know those weren't your remarks
those were prepared by representative
Tanner and um and uh I had not read them
in advance and I think it um I uh I I I
think those remarks contained a good
historical
um summary of um of what this oversight
committee has done in Prior years up
through 2009 and then I think you might
have said 2011 and with with
recommendations that came out in those
annual reports and then not much since
since then
um so I was the question is I was
wondering and maybe a question to the
chair uh maybe we could get copies of
those
um remarks for um for us because I that
this is really the first historical
summary that I've
heard on charter schools I have
um
those remarks right there could be
submitted to the part that you have
there and then copies can be made
I will do that
and then I would also ask beyond that
that our committee researcher
uh because there I I can State
emphatically there are a few holes which
have not been mentioned in there and I
don't want to go into that right here so
what we need to do is have a a real
research done by our researcher which I
think would be I think it would and
really Baseline as as to what what's
been done over the last couple decades
thank you represent dry had her hand up
first
may I just add I do also have a chart
from representative Tanner that goes
from 1995 to 2018.
documenting the number of meetings per
year whether minutes were retained
um and there's only one year here 2011
that says yes for a report so this is
I'll just add that to what's submitted
to the clerk reps and dry thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
filling in uh so I've heard that they
haven't done reports in any inkling why
there haven't been any meetings or
reports
as I understand it the committee hasn't
met so you can't do a report if you
haven't done any work okay follow-up
question any reason why the committee
hasn't met I don't know the specifics
okay so I would agree that we probably
need some research and all that for the
research represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I'm not actually sure
who I should be directing this to
because I have a little bit of confusion
on the way OLS put this together
um
um I I just say because at the very end
if if you read the way that they usually
put things together the only thing
bolded in this is the very end of the
new language by July 1st of each year
but I'm looking at the statute online
and it looks like it's a different
statue may I answer that yes please so
online one and two it says RSA
194-b21 is repealed and reenacted so the
whole thing is new
except it turns out that last section
that has just the one Bolding is
actually amending a different section
the question would be if I were looking
here at B21 it'll having only sections
one and two I'm wondering why three four
and five are not folded as I would
expect them to be are these new sections
yeah it has to do with the first lines
one and two okay
okay I understand now that's thank you
further questions
just a comment on representative
belcher's like this is something that I
think it trips people up all the time
um and and um and you gotta be
when it's repealed and reenacted you
have to take all those words as if new
um as its new language and it will never
be bolded or or stricken out
that wasn't the issue no no but I'm just
saying I know yeah we we got that it was
that was why he was wondering why it was
bolded if it was all new but it's
because starting on line 25 yes it's
referring to a different section it's
referring to be 17 as opposed to be 21.
this and so with the first top the the
section one
you know regular one is new but when you
get down to number two that is actually
amending a different thing and that was
the issue and
so in all this this is one of the
reasons and new members ought to be
aware there's another uh uh type of
paperwork we can request we call it side
by side
and the side by side shows statute as it
is now and then there's another column
which shows as Rewritten
and then referencing different statutory
language so it's really really clears up
we used to get a lot more of our
legislation with uh the embold the
Bolden uh the language like July 1 here
we could quickly see it but then you
also miss this other stuff up top which
is new
and how's that compared to what we have
in current law that's what the side by
side shows us and that's done by our
committee researcher
and later on we will do this often when
we look at you know like Community
Conference reports or we look at stuff
that's coming in from the Senate to see
how that compares
it helps us out a great deal so don't be
Asheville in the future and asking for a
side by side
further further questions yes
representative whitcock thank you Mr
chair this is this is for you following
up on our my question yesterday about
the commission uh is it possible when
you have the researcher going to a more
historical depth could provide us at
least the the members of the last
commission oh yes yes that would be part
of it thank you yeah
I in fact don't know all the members
right now
that was clear yesterday yeah
any further questions
thank you very much representative Damon
are there any questions from the public
pink cards
so with that we're going to close this
hearing
and uh we have a break until the next 15
minutes here
you got that Channel right now
right yeah
foreign
again to everybody we're ready to go
ahead with the next hearing here this is
HB 649 FN enact repealing the collection
of State education property tax uh
welcome represent Schaumburg
well thank you Mr chairman and I will
fill out a pink card which I
completely overlooked this morning and
I'd like to say uh
I feel great being here versus where I
would be with my fellow representative
fellows which would be listening to
revenue estimates for the upcoming year
so
this will be more interesting down here
I think I'd rather be with us
[Laughter]
Mr chairman and members of the New
Hampshire house education committee
thank you for the opportunity to present
today I am New Hampshire State Rep Tom
Schamberg a four-term member of the New
Hampshire house Ways and Means Committee
I represent the Merrimack District Six
representing the towns of Sutton and
Wilmette House Bill 649 doesn't act
repealing the collection of the State
education property tax this bill repeals
the Statewide education property tax and
transfers that funding of adequate
Education costs to the state general
funds the bill also repeals the low and
moderate income homeowners property tax
relief program for relief from the state
education property tax the question that
this bill brings forth before this
committee is how to reduce a mandatory
state tax on the property owners of New
Hampshire whose Reliance is supposedly
needed for the funding of public
education in April of 1999 under the
pressure of the New Hampshire state
supreme court a temporary plan to fund
New Hampshire schools was passed by the
New Hampshire legislature based on an
arbitrary
825 million dollar funding amount about
one half of the funding was new from the
hodgepodge of increased taxes and fees
and from tobacco settlement money the
other half of the plan's Revenue which
is the basis for this bill came from a
Statewide education property tax that
was no more than a renamed portion of
the local property tax this tax formula
was made permanent in 2002. generally
property tax is dealing with funding
public education in this state are out
of control the state legislative bodies
and the governor's office have been
trying for over 24 years to put a whale
into a tub of water
on average over the last eight years
property taxes have risen by 23 percent
the problem concerning the funding of
public education is that property owners
can no longer sustain these increases
where they are now paying over 70
percent of the cost of public education
from their property taxes that are
widely disproportionate from town to
town we have heard from many in our
communities the family Property Owners
the small business owners who say they
can no longer sustain these constant
increases to the cost of local funding
for public education this is a big
economic issue for the State of New
Hampshire the question arises of where
do the property owners look for help if
eight different governors of New
Hampshire since 1983 have used state tax
revenue money to fight implementation of
State funding from local public
education another series of lawsuits was
filed in July of 2022 by several
taxpayers against the state of New
Hampshire alleging that the result in
swept violates taxes being Levy at a
non-uniform rate
this case is Rand versus the state of
New Hampshire the defense of this case
by the state of New Hampshire again uses
state tax revenue monies and that's in
the fiscal report of June 30th 2022
Pages 103 I think in 104.
since 1983 the elected state
representatives and senators of both
parties have fought against reform of
public education funding in New
Hampshire from the state's general
operating fund
from the New Hampshire school funding
fairness Project Director quote the
property tax is an unfair tax as it
places greater responsibility on the low
and moderate income taxpayers than it
does on more affluent ones
and quote despite its heavy Reliance on
the property tax and in turn that taxes
heavy toll on the least well-off New
Hampshire does little to mitigate the
impact of the tax on those struggling to
make ends meet approval of this bill
House Bill 649 would address the
property tax of swept on the low
moderate and affluent Property Owners by
not having a state tax on real estate
property for public education you would
not see swept remittance to the state
there would be no excess swept collected
by various towns there would be no need
to set up a total property tax relief
program from low to moderate income
homeowners and with no Statewide
education property tax put upon any real
estate owner in the state of New
Hampshire by the New Hampshire State
Legislature the state of New Hampshire
eliminates any unconstitutional
disproportionate taxation
in Mr ardinger's letter to the house
Ways and Means Committee on September 15
2021 and before I go any further I do
have all this information for the quirk
uh to give to you at the end charts and
everything else okay uh he identified
the potentially significant
constitutional risk arising from the
current State education property tax Mr
ardinger also supplied a supplemental
statement on pages 85 through 93 of the
commission study funding released on
December 1st 2020. under commission
member statements Mr ardinger emphasized
that
quote in my view public schools are the
most important public asset in each of
our communities as a result a result
that Mr ardinger considered the most
important finding was we must fix the
current unfair distribution of state aid
resources another written comment from
Mr ardinger is New Hampshire student
outcomes are worse for districts with
greater student needs the proposed
Solution by House Bill 649 is a proper
use of legislative power to help the
property owners and the students of New
Hampshire the framework of this bill is
for property tax relief
from house Ways and Means Committee
report of January 29 2019 representative
Gary Merchant of Claremont who is still
in the legislature today made a
presentation for property tax relief he
said many homeowners are retirees who
have looked forward to staying in their
homesteads after paying off their
mortgage yet these homeowners struggle
to stay in their homes because they can
no longer afford to pay property taxes a
main reason for this challenge is the
income of many retirees significantly
declines upon retirement and he
continued with funding public education
as an artifact of colonial times when
wealth was predominantly a factor of
land Holdings over the past centuries
wealth has shifted from Real Estate to
other forms of assets as equities yet
the funding of public education remains
based on property values which do not
Encompass most wealth in modern America
and just recently on February 4th 2023 I
received an email from the Reverend J
McLeod of Wilmot one of the towns I
represent I am writing to you now
because I want working-class New
Hampshire youngsters to get the quality
education that I received a fair and
rational system will direct more
resources to poor districts in New
Hampshire we do the opposite he says
some poor districts with low property
values have to tax their residents at a
rate 10 times higher than wealthy towns
in order to spend
the same per pupil High property taxes
in these Town means that people are
losing their homes especially the
elderly and disabled
businesses can't survive in or won't
open in towns that need them the most
because the property taxes are higher
than the wealthy tones
as a parish priest I have served
Episcopal churches in New London and
Newport our funding of schools means
that the life chances of Newport kids
are much lower than for their New London
counterparts and Newport residents have
to pay far more in school property taxes
residents of poor towns get hit with a
double whammy they pay more and receive
Less in New Hampshire today education
reinforces
inequality close or quote I have
prepared exhibit a which
Sally would you mind helping
there's 10 for this side and 10 for the
other side
representative fellows is gonna
foreign
excuse me excuse me Representatives all
over there oh all right thank you Matt
Mr chair
I have prepared
exhibit a which shows the members of
this education committee the dra
completed public tax rates
for
2022.
in the community you represent
you will see in the First Column when
you eventually get the chart
I'm sorry for that Mr chairman
uh you'll see the total tax rate for
your community
then the second column you'll see the
actual local education tax rate of 2022
in the third column you'll see what the
swept tax is
this tax year and in the fourth column
you'll see
is the doe estimated swept revenue for
fiscal 24 at a dollar forty four per
thousand equalized value that your
community will have to raise under swept
in addition to what the local tax rate
will be to meet the schools districts
operating budget
and to figure out the amount of property
tax you would save on your home slash
land from not having to pay the swept
tax multiply the sweat tax times the
total assessed value of your home and
land and only you know that that is real
money that every real estate property
owner will save by implementing house
bill 649.
the amount of the swept that you'll see
in that third column as shown on this
chart for your community may seem to be
a small amount but the decrease of the
property owner would be an immense
reduction in taxes per thousand of
assessed value to their property
as Reverend McLeod wrote it is a start
to equalizing opportunities and allowing
all children to reach their potential as
state legislatures You Can level the
playing field the repeal of the
Statewide education property tax will
provide property owners and increase of
discretionary income more money in your
constituents profits for local spending
or for Town needed projects or equipment
this reduction in taxes and more money
in your constituents Pockets only works
if there is no State shifting of this
repeal tax
onto the local how much more time do you
need for that I have just two two pages
left can you please summarize it
foreign I would ask for a chance to at
least present my other chart
to you
if you can pass us out we will be
looking at those charts uh okay so
there's no need to go through the charts
right now
um
a quick summarization I'll just glance
quickly at my notes Here Mr chairman
um
the unrestricted revenue for the general
education trust funds over the last
since fiscal year 21
was 2.9 billion ahead of plan by 323
million or 12 percent and fiscal 22
3 billion 2.1
was ahead of plan by 435 million this is
a total of 759 million dollars over a
two-year fiscal period
if you decide to accept the premise and
prevent State shifting of this tax
revenue to amount to the whole to the
local taxpayer
the state legislature would have to
restructure the budget
and remit to the general fund amount of
363 million dollars and those charts
that are coming around now there's an a
chart which shows
which shows in
column H how much
of the
fiscal year 22 general fund would have
to move over or be taken off
to pay for the 363 million dollars
that'd be in line h
if you were to just do the 263 million
which came in this year
which has been applied this year
from the general fund
Revenue that's left over after the
education trust fund has been funded you
would have to take an additional online
age 13 percent
from this amount
and the last C was If This Were to have
gone in effect back in 2018
the line H would have showed you to take
23 percent of the general fund monies
that were left over after they were
distributed
to cover the 363 million dollars
in Richter ardinger's view of the
September 21st letter to the house ways
and means if the current statutes
imposing collection or remission of
State education property tax effectively
provide for such differential tax rates
on the same class of taxable property
than such differential tax rates would
likely violate the New Hampshire
Constitution
um
Mr chairman there are times when you
must sail Against the Wind of your own
political party of gradualism for the
benefit of many
I call these institutional
obstacles let us stop kicking this can
down the road and making a lasting
change on this monetary issue this bill
is about fairness and justice for the
property owners it is a viable solution
to one aspect of public education
funding
can this committee deliver for what's in
the best interest of the public
and as I close I was I did review my
chart and in discussion with the dra
the applicability date of July 1st 2023
would be open to Amendment because tax
bills have already gone out rates have
already been set for this uh upcoming
year it might be a two-year process
before that maybe this bill would come
or be to be implemented and um
this bill is more direct and less
complicated than maybe a lot of other
Maneuvers or bills that are being
presented at the present time thank you
Mr chairman thank you are there
questions from the committee
representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much representative schanberg
for uh for bringing this forward
um just a a question with respect to Mr
ardinger's um letter uh is that specific
to House Bill 649 or was that for
another bill no that was for House Bill
504 last year thank you and and um and
um I and I I I've read that letter
obviously I was connected to House Bill
504 and uh and do agree with it
um uh and I believe
um uh attorney ardinger's
um
basis for that was not so much uh of us
against the state property tax as it was
against the excess being retained by uh
municipalities and that being considered
a rebate or a tax or a reduced unequal
um disproportional tax rate is that
correct you are correct with that but he
does mention the disproportionate part
of that it is hard to resolve unless you
change the swept tax right thank you
further questions represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair thank you for
bringing this forward on Tuesday in his
address and otherwise yesterday in his
presentation the governor announced
significant proposed changes to the
adequacy formula and to my understanding
he did not plan to change the swap tax
in the formula and I realized that you
must have submitted this bill prior to
the governor's proposal but now that
that has been released do you see this
as going hand in hand with that clashing
with that if both of these were to go
forward
would you mind just repeating the last
portion a little bit louder yes as as
you get older in life if you don't buy a
hearing aids you got to have people
speak up all right thank you
representative would you see your bill
649 FN If This Were to pass would it
clash with the governor's proposal to
change other parts of the adequacy
formula
I don't think it would Clash I think it
might even help his approach
um after six years
this is the first time I've heard a real
change in the governor's uh address
about local
education how to fund it all right thank
you you're welcome further questions
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
this question I'm going to refer to your
uh dra completed public tax rates 2022
handout
um
so the the maximum spread in here
appears to be roughly five to six times
but if you eliminate the high and low
outliers we're looking at more like a
two times Gap
um so I guess my question would be
because the the foundation of your bill
is based in fairness
um are you suggesting that one town
where a property is maybe valued at 250
000 versus another District where
similar property is very valued at 500
000 where they are paying the same
amount even though it's not the same
rate is would you consider that to be an
unfair situation
no I don't set the valuations of the
towns
the dra
does that
I think that would be a question for the
dra maybe to answer
um
I just know that the the
some towns are more fortunate to have
different sources of revenue versus
other towns
yeah
are there further yes if I was just
going to ask the follow-up because I
obviously I know you don't set the rates
but just as far as the Gap there
is there is there fundamental unfairness
in paying the same amount of money
between districts for two similar
properties even if they're evaluated say
one's double value to the other
from my my personal opinion might be yes
but
I really can't answer that question okay
thank you
are there further questions from the
committee represent luno thank you very
much Mr chair so um and this sort of
follows a representative representative
belcher's question uh with respect to
fairness and just a couple of you know
quick um
well I mean I guess one observation
would would be um just looking because
you've sort of laid out the spreadsheet
for each of the towns that we represent
and um and in Hopkins and I think we uh
we take the prize with them uh total tax
rate and um I've never heard I mean I'm
I'm sure I'm sure our constituents would
love to see a tax reduction of a buck 35
but I've never heard any of Buddy in
Hopkinton say our taxes are great except
they're just a dollar 35 too high and
what that is is a lead into question why
why is this so fair when when um when
the taxpayers in tuft and Borough
essentially get a 13 tax reduction and
the taxpayers in Berlin get a 3.4
percent tax reduction don't the folks in
Berlin
need something more
they do and I was hoping that
you remove the sweat tax and then the
education committee comes forth and
readjust maybe that the disparity Aid
the aid of various communities uh from
the general
uh fund of the State of New Hampshire uh
I am just horrible so that
of all the taxes we have which we have
16 taxes
this is the one tax that goes directly
to the property owner it is the one tax
that they can say
ah this went down how did it go down and
then you can say we took the swept tax
off the state can better do this and we
can find our money elsewhere to take
care of your uh disparaging or
disproportionate amounts that each Town
might have tough and Borough to Berlin
further questions from the committee
thank you very much representative uh
representative fellows
foreign
thank you uh good morning Mr chairman
and committee members
um I'm representative Sally fellows I
represent holderness Plymouth and
Ashland I also worked at the Department
of Education for 30 years I started in
1985 in the very first
um
task I had was to write a computer
program to allocate what we now call
adequacy aid for Governor John H sununu
so just to give you some perspective of
the history of education funding in New
Hampshire since the Claremont decision
which was in
1998 thereabouts there have been many
many changes to the formula and many
many proposals to the formula so what we
are doing right now I think
I never EX at first I thought there
would be a solution and and one day it
would be like oh this is what we're
going to have and this is what we'll go
forward for it never has lasted for more
than a couple of years so it will always
be an ongoing problem but I hope we can
get to a place where it's really more
stable and just needs little tweaks
instead of big ones that being said
um I I
um wanted to give you my perspective on
the Statewide education property tax
that was enacted 20 years ago in
response to the Claremont lawsuit
and what it does what it did at the time
is it looked at the tax bills that were
being paid by property taxpayers and
said we're gonna just we're gonna
identify a portion of that as a state
tax these property taxpayers were
they've been paying this tax all along
the only thing that has changed is that
some of it has been labeled as a state
tax I call that smoke and mirrors
so that being said
um what would happen if you did as as
representative Schaumburg told you what
would happen if you did eliminate or
reduce the Statewide property tax
um the the tax let's see for for FY
property the Statewide property tax was
reduced by about a third and
that caused when you take it out of the
school funding formula it causes more
money to go to the towns
so it's not
um changing making changes to the
Statewide property tax is not a new idea
we recently have done that
my suggestion is that you retain this
bill
until you you find out what we end up
with
um at the in June you know what we vote
on end up voting for to have school
funding be for the next two years and
retaining this bill would give you an
opportunity to look at you more into the
details of that and see how we can you
know what we might want to do going
forward from that point
and to answer
um one question I heard about
the comparability of the valuation of
the same properties in different
communities I think we saw a very good
example of that during covid
when the values in Rockingham County
shot up enormously
um and in other other counties they all
went up but in other counties they went
up less and it is absolutely true you
just ask any real estate agent you take
the same house and you put it in coax
County or you put it in Portsmouth and
that same house is going to have
drastically different valuations
so that's something that could be
discussed if you retained this bill so
I'm just encouraging you to do that
thank you thank you very much are there
any questions for representative fellows
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just just to follow
up on what you just said very very true
same house in Portsmouth versus kowas
County very different valuations but is
it your feeling or your testimony that
this the resident of that house from one
one of those places the other paying the
same amount of money despite the rate is
and fundamentally unfair or unjust
well I I don't think it would be I don't
think it equalizes itself out
uh for for one thing and be just for for
one for example
um this is personal but the pers the
first proposal of the northern pass went
not on my land but across what I see
when I look out the window in my
backyard and to to base attacks on
something that can be influenced by
um people who want to move to New
Hampshire because of covid or because
the utility comes along and puts puts a
you know line behind your house changes
the value of your house that just seems
to me to be very odd
so I don't know if that helps you out
but I think that talking about this
um how it works was definitely uh
something that is is important to do
so that's that's where I'm coming from
thank you very much further questions
thank you I know you I have such a big
work Logan thank you for hearing you're
welcome
like to invite the New Hampshire school
on next New Hampshire Municipal
Association
welcome Catherine
thank you chairman Ladd and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Catherine heck and I represent the New
Hampshire Municipal Association the 234
cities and towns in New Hampshire and I
admit it's rather strange for us to be
sitting in front of you today I did fill
out a pink card there is no box to check
concerns
um so while it is checked as in
opposition are are really it's some
concerns based on timing I was not privy
to the sponsors willingness to consider
the effective date so I did just want to
go through how the current date as
written affected July 1st of 2023 could
um be somewhat concerning or problematic
on the municipal side not the school
side we're talking on the municipal side
so as you know we the municipality
collects all the taxes County local
schools City or Municipal tax and
Village District if they have it on
behalf of the county and the school we
retain it it is a formula calculate it
on paper and then we give a hundred
percent of that obligation on the
missile side back to the school district
based on what the school board decides
if the payment schedule so when we look
at the fiscal note seeing a decrease
in Revenue when we set our budgets as
you know we're all going through that
process right now regardless of whether
you're a annual town meeting town or a
city all of those budgets will be taking
effect in the next several months and
that all accounted for the current swept
formula so when we talk about the
reduction that you might see on your tax
bill because we are raising and
appropriating and for argument's sake
we're just going to use a million
dollars the school needs a million
dollars the municipality has to collect
a million dollars so the school can
operate
it doesn't matter if it's on the swept
side if that's repealed or the local
side we're still going to have to raise
that that million dollars so I don't
think that's going to change
um because we're not here to comment on
the policy of swept or on the
legislature's decision on how they want
to administer sweat we're just here to
comment on the mechanics of swept in
addition we do know that some
municipalities are able to collect and
retain maybe more than what the swept
tax is we recognize that however again
their budgets have been determined and
set based on these current numbers in
the current Formula so again any change
to that will be reflected on the local
property tax so we just wanted to point
that out as you consider and deliberate
the bill and how the timing of this is
really like in 18 months
process in order for everybody to be
prepared on how this would change the
whole tax collection process cash flow
for example because swept of course if
you are in a monthly program for example
in a municipalities able to hold those
school taxes it collects and pay it over
the course of a year that assist the
municipality who might experience you
know cash flow and then the low and
moderate income repeal we do know
anecdotally from our welfare offices
that that is a tool I believe 1.3
million dollars was allocated last year
that is a tool that helps the low and
moderate income and that does assist
it's a state program it's still a tax of
course but it does not hit the local tax
budget when any assistance can come from
another source for example so we just
wanted to point that out and I can
certainly take any questions and I thank
you for your time thank you very much
Catherine are there questions from the
committee
yes representative Woodcock thank you
chairman good morning thank you for
being here
um
unlike representative luno and
representative this this confuses me I'm
sure they I'm sure they get it very
clearly if this date was rolled out as a
representative uh Schoenberg had said at
a different date for FY 25 or 26 out
there what would be your opinion of the
bill
for impact of the bill so
from
either the school or the town side if we
just want to talk about raising and
appropriating taxes whatever the budget
is the budget is and the taxpayers pay
so it really doesn't matter how we
flip-flop it it's just a shift so I
can't I don't want to speak to a policy
that's the legislature's decision to
enact I just want to speak to if it's a
million dollars a school needs to
operate it's a million dollars no matter
where that comes from so it's state
federal and local taxation so we are
just flip flipping one for another
unless there is another formula and that
was discussed put in place that
redistributes Aid in a different way for
example but it it's the dollars that we
need so repealing the swept with no
other
program in place is just shifting it to
a fully local tax in my opinion
thank you thank you chairman thank you
very much further further questions from
the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you for your time I appreciate it
uh we do not have any other pink cards
up here are there any other members of
the public that want to speak on this
bill
not seeing any thank you very much we
will close this hearing on 6 49.
the next bill
ion
that was nice
yeah yeah
thank you that's right we've heard this
yeah
so so for those in the public we have
all this hearing Was Heard
several weeks ago so it by accident got
into this so when there is no hearing
coming up in transportation at this
point in time we will be jumping ahead
then at uh 11 30 for 5 28 so for the
members of the committee here we have
about 45 minutes to
so sorry
no no no no no
um
yeah we do
um we have sponsors see we have
what without doing it
so uh as a notice to the Republicans
here we will have a caucus starting at
11 o'clock to 11 30. then we'll start
that hearing at 11 30. and to discuss
some of the bills which we will be
exacting later today 11 o'clock so you
have about 15 minutes here or so
foreign
thank you very much Mr chair I'm uh
resident Timothy Horrigan from the town
of Stratford uh town of Durham which is
Stratford County District 10 as probably
everybody in the room knows already so
and I passed two eyes around actually
both of which I emailed to the committee
but it doesn't hurt to have the paper
uh as a backup which is uh one is in a
there's like a uh there's an amendment
which uh basically corrects an objection
that was in the fiscal note so
apparently
um the body of the bill has introduced
which I think was the same problem last
time although they did they mention last
time is that there's a three cent
payment and the 27 Cent payment which it
adds up to 30 but apparently it really
needs that up to 40. so I changed the 27
to 37 and if that's uh
and there may be other changes that need
to be made to the bill but it leaves it
up to you you folks so it's um looks
very familiar to those who are on the
committee last year virtually identical
to HP 1660 which actually came within a
few votes of passing the pick difference
is the effective date of course
and this time around the code size with
the beginning of a biennial budget cycle
um
and uh so it makes two changes the RSA
189 level 29 11a which deals with fruit
and nutrition programs the first thing
in section one this would be a permanent
change would be to require schools for
my breakfast in addition to lunch
the second change is is uh shown in
section two to four of the bill and this
would apply only to July 1st 2025 which
is a little over two years from now and
of course uh
that's the opinion of the state's fiscal
year 2026 fiscal year I'm always a
little bit confused by that Lakes we'll
be starting uh 2024 on July 1st 2023 but
and um it would reduce and so it's much
more complicated than it is but it
passed the law it reduces qualifying
families co-pay for reduced price meal
to Zero from the current
um
30 cents a day for breakfast and 40
cents a day for lunch and uh this leaves
the existing distinction between free
lunch reduced price lunch families and
police how long without you know the
bureaucratic stuff that goes with the
distinction you know it's
not necessarily
how we would write education law if we
were starting from scratch but we're not
so I I respect that and so there's about
5 000 students in reduced price category
we'll get free lunches and breakfasts um
and I think I think that's a good thing
it makes it easier for the families it
also saves the school districts a lot of
trouble collecting all those small uh
co-pays in fact I think they've been
paying their breakfast all along because
they could be a
there's some families who are like
paying three cents and it's not worth
collecting a three three cent charge so
it's a section four just puts the law
books back the way after the two years
Sunset back to the way it is right now
so that uh and the reason I'm doing for
just two years is because I'm fairly
certain that there's Federal funding
readily available from the Biden
administration's economic and pandemic
relief packages to finance the expanded
program in section two and the federal
funding we would well what I've heard
another committee or maybe it's just one
describes a bucket for receiving the
funds so the federal funding we go into
that bucket and we could receive money
from any Source not just from the
federal government but the private
sector or even the state government
itself and we even just put it into the
money into the general fund they put it
into the meals for students funds and um
if this proves to be popular and
feasible we could I mean expand make it
permanent not to I know the governor
said he wants to he wants to concentrate
one-time projects but um you know
there's nothing to stop us from having
permanent projects too and
we would address that two years from now
as part of the 26-27 biennial budget and
my estimate is
did across about 375 000 a year above
and beyond what our state government our
state public schools are already
spending and right now that money comes
from the families the students if
they're paying if they're paying out but
some of them having difficulty doing and
I'm confident the federal funding can be
found and even this is a fairly
inexpensive program so I think would be
what we're spending our own money on and
we do
we can't guarantee this always be the
case but we are currently running a
surplus and the governor is even selling
them the governor is talking rather
expansively on Tuesday he almost sounds
anyway I want to say what he sounded
like but almost sounded
um and um there was there has been some
concern about startup costs but my
attention my hope would be and if that
needs an amendment then you should fix
it but I think the startup cost for the
schools that aren't serving meals
um could be covered under the rubric of
the phrase from the bill which is UN
reimbursed costs of breakfast and lunch
meals so anyway this restores expands
the free lunches which was
a very valuable uh very popular program
during the pandemic and I know in my
school district and thinking virtually
all others they decided to just give
every kid the lunch for free especially
when they're while they're delivering
the lunches
to students at home on the they sent the
school bus around every house in my
district well every house of the
children they didn't stop at my house I
have no kids but um
they just including the lunch with
everybody because if it didn't cost that
much there was funding for it and also
there thought there were privacy
concerns because then believe me the
kids would notice and the parents would
notice which houses had the bag with the
sandwich or whatever the lunch is and
which ones didn't get along with the so
that's um
so that's my bill it's not a new bill it
came pretty close to passing this year
and I have a better chance uh I mean
came pretty close last year and then I
hope it'll do even better this year so
yes I'm willing to take prices may not
be able to answer them but I'm certainly
willing to take them back thank you for
being willing to take questions
um and thank you Mr chairman I have a
question about section five the repeal
no
um looking at that section of Statute
unless I have the wrong one
um one B is related to monies received
by the state treasurer shall be
accounted for in the state's accounting
system as General Revenue of the state
with the exception of and number 383
relates to money's deposited in the New
Hampshire Solid Waste Management fund
okay so I'm wondering how that
is it three
383 oh
well maybe it uh
um thank you for thank you for catching
it that's a simple Amendment if that's
uh
yes we
um yeah we don't want to repeal the
solid waste fund when this program
sunsets because that program may not
sunset at the same time I don't see a
388 yeah
yeah that was the idea though yeah this
bill would create the program for two
years and I I certainly would not be uh
I certainly uh if I'm still here as a
member of the legislature or as a
private citizen either way I said who
could be in favor of repealing the
sunset and keeping the program going
probably depending on how it works I'm
sure it'll work fine but you never know
but you know that's uh I'm embarrassing
I missed missed the typo although I
suppose Mario the blame goes with OLS
but um yes it was my bill so I I
apologize you're certainly welcome to
fix that so
oh thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question representative I need to
apologize to the committee and to you
for not being here at the beginning of
your test that's fine oh I I wanted just
zero in on the effect of this bill and
as I read it it would take the 5 000
students you've identified who are now
getting reduced priced lunch and make
lunch free for those 5 000 students
thank you yeah exactly so just the price
of the reduced price meal is now zero
rather than 40 cents or whatever
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question uh because we've
been talking about breakfast and lunch
in the committee a bit let me make sure
your amendment is only with uh
article um letter B under this so does
this does the the first line in your
bill still apply that says each School
Board shall make breakfast and lunch
available during school hours to every
pupil under its jurisdiction yeah all
right I was wondering if me ask a
follow-up yeah
we've discussed this does this include
charter schools and is this a a
part one article 28a mandated expense to
those schools that are not doing
breakfast yet
um well that was it was um
you know I've heard that heard that
before with a similar bill
um that was we do have this meals for
students funds so my
hope is and you may need to tweak the
wording of it to make that possible but
like the start of cost could be included
as the unreimbursed costs so like
certainly I mean
you know it's not an unfunded mandate if
you fund it and I think it's I think
it's like not it can be funded I think
um without uh you know without sending
the state into bankruptcy or anything I
think that's a fairly modest in my
opinion it's a modest cost so you know
what's up thanks
yes I asked also is our chartered Public
Schools included in this
um that's been a matter of controversy
many of them don't serve lunch uh
this just talks about the school boards
so
um so even though every
so I think it only plays that's a
question you may have to work out for
yourself in the exact session this does
talk about
schools that are under the ages of
school boards the most charter schools
are are not even though they're all
assigned to an SAU there are a few
exceptions to that so that would uh
maybe I want to include Charter
chartered schools that would need more
language to it but that creates a lot of
difficulty because most of the
also some of them don't even have
cafeteria facilities at the moment and
but
that may be something that may be
something the committee wants to look at
uh while you're executing the bill but
um I'd like to get to Charter Schools
involved but that may take some more
steps so thanks thank you
chair thank you for bringing this
forward you mentioned that this has a
sunset currently of two years what
happens if there's a surplus in the fund
what happens with the extra money when
the sun sets over and this is no longer
happening
thank you
well it goes I believe it says it's
non-lapsing and continually appropriate
to the Department of Education so except
of course
um except of course we're also like uh
abolishing
abolishing the uh thing that does the
funds I think if the fund lapses my I
I was almost applying to finance two
years ago but I luckily I got a reprieve
but I think those
funds would go back into the general
fund if that happens but
thank you that's something you can
address uh that might be another detail
that needs to be worked out better than
that is but yeah
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so just to clarify
the intent of this bill is not to
include Charter Schools is that correct
no it's a worthy goal but I think we
have to start with the school boards
because they as I've discovered they
don't all have
even school lunches at the moment but so
the answer to my question is yes yes sir
thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um I noticed that those established a
fund for the program but requiring
breakfast at schools that aren't
currently doing it that's going to
require staff it's going to require more
facilities what's the funding mechanism
for all of that
well I was that
um well that that would ultimately be
for the finance committee that this
company decide but we do have this fund
which I think the way the law is written
and I'm not a lawyer but I think
startup costs could be included and we
certainly could uh explicitly
explicitly say so and then estimate what
the startup cost would be they seem to
have
that seems to be a pretty good handle on
what they what this what the startup
costs would be so but um thank you
uh thank you Mr chair and I apologize if
I didn't understand this the the first
first time you said it um
okay
um but and and actually and I know I
didn't understand it uh a year or two
ago when when the first time
um this came through but could you sort
of walk through what this you know what
like like on lines 15 and 16 you've got
a three cent reimbursement and then
there's a 27 Cent reimbursement where
that comes from what it's for what uh
what and what it all means and I noticed
that there was something in the in the
budget note 40 cents versus 30 cents
yeah that's what it's all that about oh
good question well that was um I mean
existing I'm taking the existing law so
I'm not I'm only creating I'm only
changing the things that are well as you
know straight and uh so right now it
says uh and that this is a law that
established the school breakfast program
which was uh past two or three years ago
so
like the like in line 13 right now says
it's such School providing breakfast
meals to pupils so now it says breakfast
crossout meals and lunch did peoples and
meter exceed and then there's that same
language breakfast meal it's a change to
breakfast and lunch
and uh
then also says the department shall
provide funding from the meals for
breakfast and lunch and uh
so that's and then some paragraph C is
new too so that establishes the fund
that the the primary education would be
using to provide that funding
follow up yeah and so the funding is
this three Cent and 27 Cent
I think if my amendments passed it'll be
37 cents because apparently the people
who are at the fiscal know that the
Department of Education uh they rightly
played out that three and 27 adds up to
30 not 40 which is the amount of money
we need to get the three lunches and a
final follow-up on that well so is is is
that what it costs schools to provide to
provide a a meal to a student they do it
for 40 cents no it's significantly more
than that but some of the rest of it's
made up from
from various various various other
sources including
um
equally selling meals to the adults in
it and there's money kicked into the
school district and there's Federal
funding this and even if you're paying a
full price student meal that's also
subsidized so the and I forget the exact
so this is funding on top of this is an
addition to what's already have it's all
everybody who eats there probably
including the adults but certainly all
the students they're all they're all
subsidized to some degree another I'm
just increasing the subsidy for this
group that's in the middle in between
the free meal and the oak rice meal okay
thank you
oh my I haven't haven't uh haven't heard
from them much this year but I did work
with them and to speak my
superintendent's office and um like two
years ago when I did this originally
this this is basically the repeat of
something that narrowly failed last time
so I mean I
can
foreign
thank you
probably not
foreign
thank you Mr chairman I'm I move ought
to pass
a second
please then purchased Me by cordelli's
second Engine with the Motions made by
Prince
yes I do um from the sponsor I I've
heard she said previously Charter School
additional monies went through the
fiscal committee the department now
draws a warrant for additional monies
for charter schools so there is no need
to go through the fiscal committee
despite the report no longer being
needed the Department of Education
continues to do it amounting to
approximately 15 hours of Staff time the
fiscal committee has never once asked a
question about the report
but it's just not needed this is it's
not going through the the uh the
channels that this original RSA
describes and so it's out of date
nothing
further discussion
yes representative luno thank you thank
you very much Mr chair so so
um
just because the um
just because the fiscal committee may
not be interested in this report I'm not
sure I I guess having not seen the
report it's unclear to me whether or not
the report would have value otherwise to
either make sure that the um that the
department of Ed education is properly
funding uh Charter Schools or if um and
there are a couple of wrinkles I think
in terms of the funding of charter
schools whether you're a um
chartered from the Department of
Education or your chartered and I I
don't think we have any charter schools
that are currently chartered directly
conversion schools but there are
different funding parameters I think
depending upon how you're charted
chartered and I think the value of the
report may still um
um still have some Merit and um and
possibly
rather than directing the
the the report to the finance committee
possibly it should be directed I mean to
the fiscal committee possibly it should
be directed to the finance committee and
then the education committees
okay further discussion on that
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman it's not that
there's not a report it's just that
there does not need to be the multiple
reports that are in this um section A
lot right now and going through the
fiscal committee and it's not it's my
understanding they still report things
but they don't need to do it uh every
time that they get a money
dispersed so the idea would be to cut
down on the number and put it to the
right place that's accepting the report
right now
further discussion representative thank
you
um looking at the statute the report
goes to the fiscal committee for each
payment made during the year to a
chartered school and contains the name
and name and address of the school the
amount of payment and the number of
students currently enrolled so if the
intent is to verify that they're getting
the right amount based on the number of
pupils I think that that is a doe
responsibility since they are making the
payments rather than the fiscal
committee
further discussion
uh representative you know
any kind of reports that come back to
the education committee
probably would never be read
we have numerous reports by Statute we
say report to the various education
Committee of the house and the Senate
and we don't meet during the summer time
at all
and in the spring we're unloading you
know and voting and we're very rarely
are looking at information coming in
such we talk about here in this bill
and the same thing for the fall
um so there's time I don't think the
sending these reports to the education
committee would be you know beneficial
at all
um I don't I know for half that stuff's
not even read that we get we get Oodles
of stuff coming in
and it Stacks out there on that desk so
so to that and I I I agree with that
um that stuff does stack up however you
know I I think since I've been on the
education Community actually prior to
being on the education committee I'd
certainly be looking at um the uh the
doe grants to uh to a public school
districts do they have a um a similar
report that um that they have available
for uh for Charters have have people
been seeing that and have people
compared that to what um what is being
proposed in this repeal bill
I mean just to make sure we're not
losing losing some piece of information
yeah I mean I
I can't respond to that you know have
you ever seen one of these reports
pardon me have you seen one of these
reports no I haven't either
and I ask them if I want to see one of
those reports well maybe if you see one
maybe you want to see more I mean I
don't know I don't know
all right so um so so
um Mr chair does is this an this isn't
early do we need to act today
none of these bills that we have left on
this list are early bills right right so
they all have to be acted on by March
16th
so so with with this one here
um and I'm just sort of talking out loud
and so I hope you know uh Mel I hope
that's okay on this that that it would
seem to be this this should be
20 to nothing or something close to that
one way or the other on this committee
is there anything we can do to try to
get it to that
hey if you can suggest a way to do that
I agree I for all the bills Hit the
Floor has no recommendation especially a
bill like this yeah which is this is
being submitted To Us by what doe right
right right but we didn't actually hear
from Dewey oh actually Diana was it
though yes but she was but but she
didn't have a lot of background in no
but it was mentioned that doe this is a
technical thing I've got that yeah but I
I guess as as long as we can be assured
that there's that that there's a report
available that Zoe will continue to make
a report available and that that
whatever they're making available is at
least contains the information that's in
in this report then I think we could
probably get there
I can't believe that the reports which
they receive
are not available they're public
documents
I haven't seen it well I know yeah
yeah reps and dry
excuse me thank you reports on charter
school funding can be found in the doe
website at any time the Senate passed an
identical Bill SB 25 by Voice vote
January 19th of this year
who was that from Maureen Mooney okay
the sponsor
represent like us
I remember correctly when the doe did
talk to us
they said that public schools are not
doing this particular report that the
charter schools are doing those other
reports that the public schools are
doing but this particular report where
they have to report
every single
payment
is not the public schools don't do this
and so that was at any rate that was an
answer to that blue nose question
are there further comment yes
representative cascadden um just to add
to that
um what they have on the department of
Ed website and the this is the only
thing I could find I don't know if
there's something else was the Charter
School per pupil aid for 21 22 so it it
lists their total ADM
they're per pupil Aid and their
differentiated AIDS so those are the
there's no detailed Financial or fiscal
reports like there are for the public
schools and their accountability plan
really has no fiscal uh information tied
to it either it's all goals driven and
how they're going to measure it so
to me to take it off the books leaves it
open-ended for accountability in the on
the fiscal side of it
further discussion represent Myler oh
thank you San cordelli thank you Mr
chair would it be possible to hold this
and have somebody somebody from the
Department who actually deals with this
come and provide some sense of
clarification notwithstanding
representing Mooney's uh communique but
I'd like to hear somebody who actually
manages this thing that can be able to
give us an indication and if in fact uh
it is what it is we may be able to have
a 2020 vote on this but right now I'm
not going to vote for this unless I get
some information directly from the
Department
further discussion representative
cordelli
I I think that the main report
um that would be of interest is what was
just pointed out on doe website that
shows the uh the enrollment and the uh
the amount that they're eligible for
even including the differentiated Aid I
think that that's the information that
people would be looking for
further discussion
so we have a motion on the floor
that's ought to pass
call the rule
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yeah
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortielo yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell representative
Lane no
representative Luna no representative
Ellison oh representative Wilcox
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no
chairman LED yes
10 years 10 days
motion
okay what we're going to do is we're
going to hold this right here all right
okay good and uh we will request that
Doe appear
and provide this information
uh if it's supportive of what I hear
from
representative drive there
um then you know we're just going to
continue on and March was
you know tried to you know figure this
out a direction we can go so we can come
onto the floor with something that's a
little bit Yeah more
something on consent
yeah yeah yeah
okay so what we're going to do is close
this portion of the executive session
down we're going to leave this so Madam
clerk we have a motion on the floor on
the pass was it 10 10 where that's where
we're stopping
hold good you got the word hold in big
print big printed printed okay
alrighty
um
going down
um it's 382 we've done that already 6
34. I'm going to hold off in this one in
case there's a couple bills we know that
there's probably Mutual consent here and
I'm going to put them at the end in case
somebody has to scoot out of here and we
want to continue exacting
so I'm going to jump over to 441 right
now or down to it
eliminating residency requires for
Public School attendance
representative
thank you I move itl on House Bill 441
is there a second
second representative motion
so the motion on eliminating residency
requirements for public school
attendance is itl made by representative
and second by represent dry
representative do you have any comments
yes thank you I think this is an
interesting idea but I don't think that
the funding formula in the state
supports
this type of movement between school
districts at this point in time
represent dry do you have any comments
yes I think it's it's a complicated
subject and we haven't given it
certainly nearly enough time to talk it
through
further comments
I have one comment that I'd like to make
is that been involved with Athletics all
my life and
um knowing and seeing things like this
happened where I was in charge of the
intersclastic Athletics for the state of
Alaska we saw certain schools become
hockey schools
and they were the division one champions
for a year after year after year simply
because they're going to where they want
to go to school
and it really kind of you know
eliminated any other school from being
competitive at all so I agree I think
that there is our number of issues
Athletics is just one that
um
we need to discuss are even to
um you know maybe pursue in the future
but the way this bill is written right
now I agree I think it needs to be itl
further discussion
ma'am clerk on 441
thanks chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Lane yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes 28 zero news
any problems with consent no good thank
you
okay
okay the next bill which we have going
down is hb104
relative to multi-style bathrooms and
locker rooms and schools
so in 104 I I recognize representative
cardelli for a motion uh thank you I'd
like to move like to pass
is there a second represent Belcher
represent cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman
um uh I believe that this bill we hear a
lot of testimony about building codes
and uh the impact on this bill but it
seems to me from that testimony that
this is current building code compliant
future building codes who knows what's
going to happen the legislature votes on
building codes so if some building code
comes down in a year two years whatever
it might be there's no guarantee that we
are going to modify or pass the building
codes as is and change what is current
law in terms of the building codes so
that is my primary reason in supporting
this
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair uh I would just I
would just say that for
going back in history this has always
been done keeping male and female spaces
separate for a very good reason
it is entirely clear that on average men
are stronger it is entirely clear that
on average men are more dangerous it is
entirely clear that on average women
receive more sexual attention than men
do and it is for these reasons that we
have to protect female spaces
further discussion
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair
I want to read this brief message from
my colleague Leslie McGregor who's a
nurse practitioner who is director of
the Bayard Health Center at Kobe server
college for a number of years
and I believe lives in Plainfield
to The Honorable members of the House
Education committee HP 104
oversimplifies the question of gender it
is unfortunate that the construct of
gender is more complicated than we have
always thought but wishing it were
simpler doesn't make it so
we know there are individuals who don't
feel the gender they were assigned at
Birth fits their self-image we know that
some are born with ambiguous genitalia
mismatched genitals and gonads or sex
chromosomes that are other than XX or XY
this is biology the fact that these
phenomena are relatively rare doesn't
take away our responsibility as a
society to make space for anyone for
whom these things are true
so saying a locker room or bathroom
needs to be same-sex doesn't solve
anything it simply denies the existence
of the examples I listed that's a
horrible thing to do to anyone isn't it
and she says please vote this bill down
and focus on making our schools
bathrooms and locker rooms safe for
everyone that would be a real
accomplishment
I concur
further discussion
representative cascadden
thank you just want to remind that um
that really it isn't just black and
white
but schools are service providers to
kids
and what's best for kids
is not this bill so I won't vote for it
further discussion representative Myler
thank you Mr chair
we live in a different time now
and
um
it's not like when I grew up
boys or boys girls were girls
it's a different time
I vividly remember
several years ago when we dealt with the
Trans athlete issue
and we had a young
student up here before this committee
she came and she testified
it was a first time publicly that she
came out
and she said to us you know
I love to play soccer and none of none
of my students one of my friends at home
know I'm trans
it's the first time
her mother Then followed up
and went through
an assessment of what they have done to
support their daughter
the hormonal treatments that went
through
the psychological issues that they went
through both as a family and as an
individual
herdicide her decision
to change her sexual orientation was not
an easy one
because of satire issues that that are
there with Transit individuals
it had a profound impact upon me
I I it's it's an area that I don't know
much about
I admit that
but she
this small student
had a major impact upon my look at when
somebody doesn't just decide oh I'm
going to be a boy I'm going to be a girl
it's not an easy decision
but when they make that decision
how does society treat that individual
that's the issue here
and if if an individual has decided that
they want to
come out and whatever choice they make
then where do they go to the bathroom
where do I go to the bathroom
in this case
does she have to go to the male bathroom
she looks just like a girl
dresses just like a girl
she's gonna go to the male bathroom
because it says that was what her birth
identification was
this is a very important issue for us to
deal with here because we've got a lot
of kids
who have made this decision with their
family
we often talk about parental rights here
in this state in this committee
students make that decision not by
themselves
I would encourage you not to support
this OTP motion
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you Mr chairman
um we have also heard testimony from
someone who identified as gender fluid
and they changed their gender identity
in their mind
sometimes on a daily or weekly basis
and had to actually decide which soccer
team the girls or the boys soccer team
they wanted to play on
I have no idea what their genitalia
looks like
um and
um but how how do we accommodate that
um if someone's gender is changing on a
weekly basis
um
you know the culture is changing in many
different ways
um some of it is very troubling to me
but I certainly respect that every
person is an individual
and every person deserves respect but I
don't think that this is the way to show
that respect further discussion
representative woodcock
a couple of things
uh came clear during the dialogue from
the bill
one was the first word that says all and
I asked about that as he recalls and the
building Folks by all he said that would
mean that every public school would have
to eliminate all their gender-neutral
bathrooms in that school
says right there Paulie all so the ones
you have here you have to go out now
that's the first thing the second thing
is we have team at the team at the team
that go to schools in Haverhill and
schools and Conway and schools and
Wolfeboro where the visiting team comes
in they go in the office of the locker
room all the boys go on the girls locker
room and all the girls go in the boys
locker room depending what site they
happen to be on that particular day in
that particular team
what happens then the violation of the
law you're trying to pass well those
kids can't well haven't changed outside
as far as gender neutral and and
representative cordiality's gender fluid
sorry soccer example the nhia clearly
has rules for that they don't go one to
you today one to you tomorrow come on
Glenn that doesn't happen we know that I
don't believe that does not happen I I
didn't say that they should they went
from one team to another they had to
choose which team they wanted to be yeah
it's very clear and it's highest when
they choose as a set for season for the
year the last thing is the the we heard
testimony again there are over 700 trans
to athletes right now in New Hampshire
excuse not athletes trans students in
New Hampshire right now
in our schools and that with that piece
they talked about the problems they had
with some of these youngsters who were
forced into the genitalia appropriate
locker room and the harassment
additional harassment they got at that
point in time
so if we've taken out gender neutral so
we give them no option and now we're
gonna force them into a discriminary
place I think we're going backwards by
trying to help youth in the 21st century
thank you
thank you Mr chairman I listened to the
testimony the other day and I heard
people who were afraid to go to the
bathroom and so held it all day because
there might be somebody the opposite sex
in their bathroom and then I heard
somebody that that would hold all day
because they wouldn't
be respected for the choice that they
had made and I think there's a middle
ground here somewhere that we have not
examined I'm going to vote ought to pass
and if it doesn't pass I would like to
retain this because I think we can work
this out but I don't think that we are
are at that place yet
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just like to
clarify a bit of the language in the
middle too it opens all multi-stall
bathrooms
um so the gender neutral sort bathrooms
that are single occupancy or family
restrooms
um would not be affected by this bill
it's only multi-stall restrooms and I
think the intent of the bill is exactly
that to not have biological male and
biological females occupying the same
space in the same restroom
um I've heard a lot of talking about
gender gender the idea of gender as a
social construct that goes back a long
time in social sciences Judith Butler
and all we have never ever
assigned bathrooms based on gender we
have always assigned them based on sex
now clerk would you please call the rule
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative Petter now yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Lane no representative
Luna no
representative Ellison yeah
representative
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no
representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd no
eight years
12 days
Works nice uh uh representative McDonald
I recognize you for a motion thank you
Mr chair I'd like to move to retain
I will second that
okay and to speak on the retained motion
I think both sides made some good points
there just doesn't seem to be a need for
this at this time I do not believe that
this will really accomplish anything and
it could discriminate against a
particular group of New Hampshire
students no matter how small that group
and I do not believe as representative
dry mentioned the building code would
comply with this as well so at the very
least we should wait to make a decision
on this until that were to be updated
and again there are several places
within the bill as worded that I find
con confusing and conflicting with
existing statutes such as the word all
as was mentioned I think it's
restrictive of many groups of students
who might find themselves in certain
categories under many groups of
different gender identities and for this
reason I do not believe this bill should
pass at this time and should be
reconsidered by the committee at a later
time thank you
and I I will respond that I think
representative McDonald uh said it all
very very well there's a lot of work
that needs to be done on this before I
will be prepared to move on this topic
so uh I very much support the the need
for retention
further discussion from the committee
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher no
representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no
Representative no
representative Myler
representative Cornell no
representative Lane no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no
representative Wilcock
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no representative cat scadden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd
yes
six Cas 14 Nays
okay is there a motion representative
Miss Dame is going to have a motion
please
thank you Mr chair I move itl
is there a second
a second that is for sure so a motion
for itl on this bill made by represent
Damon a second by representative
woodcock
so in addition to what I already stated
about the reality that we're trying to
oversimplify gender inappropriately
I think it's worth noting the
substantially increased risk of suicide
in the population of people who are
trans
and requiring Single Sex bathrooms is
essentially outing them whether they're
ready or not
we are shared Humanity
trans rights and safety can coexist
we don't need to be protecting these
students from each other the students
spoke so eloquently when we did the
hearing
we need to itl this bill and respect
this population thank you
further discussion
Is there further discussion from the
committee
represent McDonald thank you I have a
question what is the procedure if this
motion fails because the prior two
motions also failed it'd be a no
recommendation all right thank you
further discussion
Smiler do your red lights on there just
didn't know if you had a yeah
you're good okay no no don't worry okay
so not see any more discussion from the
committee Madam clerk would you please
call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli no
representative Lucas no
representative Ford
yes
representative Belcher no
representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no representative quarter to Yellow no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes
representative Elaine yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes
representative cascadin yes
representative Damon
yes
chairman Champion
well we got wait till all the things
that
chairman lad no
is there a reconsideration on your vote
because I haven't put the gavel down yet
yeah
you'd have to wait you're currently yay
okay
so this bill comes out with no
recommendation
right here
and I assume representative cordelli you
do the OTP okay
okay uh
the next one down below 104 we're going
to we did retain 352.
uh
hb505 represent Belcher you're
recognized for a motion
thank you Mr chair I would move itl
sir second
represent Belcher is there a discussion
yes
let's see
um so this this bill is about
Comprehensive Mental Health um being
added to School curriculum
um first I'd like to say the word
comprehensive I think that throws a lot
of us for a little bit of loop I'm not
quite sure exactly what that means I am
aware of some other programs that have
come in under the broad term
comprehensive and they've been
less than desirable ultimately
uh second
I believe mental health education should
really be undertaken only by those
trained professionals who are trained
and licensed to do so trained and
licensed and prepared to handle any
potential Fallout that may occur during
such training
again
um
when we get into ideas such as self-care
mindfulness and other things believe it
or not we're actually starting to bump
up against
um ideological ethical political and
even religious ideas that may be
controversial
and I know certain uh quite a lot of
parents have spoke to me about these
things in schools that they don't want
to have their children educated on in
schools because they feel these are
values they should be inculcated on at
home
and finally the curriculum argument this
is either a local control issue where
it's not it can't be one only when we
don't like it versus you know vice versa
and it says very clearly in the bill
that this is curriculum
further discuss
the discussion I guess I'm going to add
a few words here
um this bill is relative to
comprehensive mental health education in
schools comprehensive kind of bothers me
here we're also getting into the realm
of
saying the schools that we're going to
get in this domain and I don't know
who's going to be responsible for
teaching it's sort of what represented
Belcher just mentioned
but I also know that there's another
bill that's coming forward from the
Senate and Senate Bill 151 which has
bipartisan Support over in the Senate
which does not have a financial note
attached to it
so my my position on this I'd rather see
this bill retained in this committee
until we have our eyeballs on 151 and we
can move that best Bill forward thank
you
further discussion
representative thank you Mr chair I'm
going to support the itl motion not
because of the comments that
representative Belcher mentioned because
I disagree with much of what he said
other than the issue that this is a
local control issue thank you
further discussion representative Luna
so thank you thank you very much Mr
chair
um and uh with with no disrespect to
what represent mileage has suggested I
would um I I would support a retain
um um motion on this to see that uh to
make sure Senate Bill 151 gets over here
and um uh and and how that uh and how
that reads because I think it is
important uh that we um that we do
something given the um just just given
the situations that were that that I
think we're facing today with uh with
young people and whether that means
having having a little bit better
definition to what comprehensive means
but you know I'm not I'm not I guess
thinking that this is a um uh you know a
mindfulness session or or or or or
something from a from a psychology from
a psychotherapist or psychologist but
something that that talks about access
to services and um you know services
covered by insurance and and Medicaid
and signs to look for like what judge
Broderick talks about uh and how we go
about helping others to um to do that I
I don't see this as a as a clinical type
of uh uh type of thing for our students
but something to that that like what
we're trying to do with the information
on the back of student ID cards to just
give them some place a turn
um and um and and you know make sure
that our community is sensitive to to
helping out or or you know a you know a
classmate recognize that that that maybe
they you know
you know need need a little bit more
support or access to Services that's all
I'm thinking so I I think I think
representative Ladd has has suggested
maybe a good way forward with this yes
if you don't mind I like to just add a
comment
um
I talked to the counselor up at
Woodsville High School we're not a very
big school probably about two 50 to 60
kids approximately the counselor called
me up and indicated we're losing the
assistant I have in the office to work
with students with whether I'm providing
information guidance or counseling the
counselor has the proper standards or
certification required to work with kids
that have you know are are perceived as
having some kind of a mental behavioral
type issue whichever it may be
and she indicated to me she's really
concerned that by losing this person
that she's had working with or under her
direct supervision
that there's not going to be the
Personnel within the building other than
herself that's properly trained to know
how to counsel and work with students
that come looking for this type of help
in the past up there in Wood soil we've
used ammunition
umnusic Community Mental Health
they came into the building served that
purpose what's going on now though
zamanusic is so overloaded with people
in the general public they can't afford
to let an individual come in a school
they don't have the Personnel either
so the question being does the school
district now have the funding to hire a
person that's going to properly do it
they understand that we just can't let
anybody in this school do this because
the consequences could be horrible
they don't have the money
so now here we are at a position where
we have a huge mental health issue in
our schools
other health impaired I mentioned in the
IEP area is a skyrocketing
category within special education now
that deals with mental health issues
so I for one feel that this is a
critical issue in our society in our
schools
but we better make sure that we're going
to do it with the proper personnel and
is a classroom teacher was not qualified
to do this
I don't believe many teachers are
and so therefore we need to make sure
we're hiring the right people to do this
so this this topic needs as as
representative has indicated I also
agree needs to be retained we need to be
working with the Senate right now it's
already doing this with 151 but we also
need to be working with other groups
such as Community Mental Health and
finding out how we can best satisfy this
and accomplish it in schools
representative woodcock
thank you chairman and I would concur
with your thinking as well as
representative lunos
um I have not seen SB 151 I'd like to
see that
um I do know by by regulation mental
health uh as an entity is dialogue in
the rules and in the curriculum
currently in the school
um so obviously comprehensive I don't
know what that means in this bill that
being said I I will not support the IPL
but I'd much appreciate if you putting
our retained Motion in
person Damon
thank you Mr chair
I'm opposed to the itl I would support
the retain
although honestly I would have preferred
to pass it
I want to emphasize that there is a
difference between education and therapy
there's no difference between teaching
students markers of depression or
anxiety and teaching them risk factors
for heart disease you don't make the
condition happen because you acknowledge
that these diagnoses exist
depression for example does not always
present
the way that people stereotypically
would think
a person can superficially appear to be
going along just fine when in fact they
are not very well at all
in their Mental Health
I would hope that we could retain it
look at the Senate bill and come out
with something that does provide
education on mental health conditions to
our students sooner than later
represent dry and then represent leckers
thank you
Mr chairman
I'm never a fan of long lists as part of
a mandate but is there anything that
would preclude a school from teaching
Comprehensive Mental Health even if we
don't declare it here that it needs to
be done
I for one I'm not qualified to answer
that question because I don't know
what's meant by Comprehensive Mental
Health
um I don't have an answer for that uh I
think we're we're starting to step into
a domain which I'd be very careful of
walking into with
why say may not be appropriate in trying
to help somebody and to what degree do
how far do I go
um
represent Belcher thank you if I could
just clarify when I when I brought up
ideas of self-care and mindfulness I
wasn't just pulling these out of The
Ether I did actually research what other
states are doing under what they call
comprehensive mental health education
and these are under that rubric
representative
um I believe it was mentioned during the
public hearing
that
Mental Health on the level that
representative Luna was talking a basic
this is what it is and you know places
to go is taught in health it is part of
the health am I not right yeah it is
part of the health program now and so
that's the question is what beyond that
means comprehensive because we are being
taught in mental health it's part of the
the standards or whatever that you know
it's being taught now on the level which
you were talking about rep luno and so
how much deeper do they want us to go
that's you know representative cascadden
thank you Mr chair
um the Ed rules 306 40 our health
education programs
which also identifies
um that the goal is to practice Health
enhancing behaviors and and health risk
but there's also a specific
identification to mental health as one
of the requirements and I think
representative Woodcock had pointed that
out
and certainly we're having conversations
here about two extremes of the term
mental health and I think until that's
clarified what do you mean by mental
health I have a mental health today does
it show no I hope it doesn't
um as opposed to you know you're talking
to a general group in school you're
going to generalize and just make them
aware of some of the risk factors
where they could lead how they can
intervene how they can change their
adapt their behaviors
whereas we don't know if that Senate
bill is really talking about
therapy
or extensive Behavioral
supports that are going to change
diagnoses behaviors that are really
interfering with a child's day-to-day
function in life so the term mental
health gets thrown out gets thrown out
in a field like it's
you know all kinds of things but for
where a public school perspective
it is it is touched upon it is taught
um in a very broad sense it does not
deal with the health teacher does not
provide individual therapy by any means
and guidance counselor would not provide
any therapy either unless they're highly
trained
so I think that information needs to be
vetted out like I think you said that's
what we had uh when we looked at 306 and
we added in Wellness topics and such
that which are there in 306 yeah
um you're correct these are not getting
I don't know how far this is getting
down into the weeds right right here uh
I know how we've been functioning and
the counselor up at Woods will explain
that to me
um and there's many schools that are
having even a specialist when they delve
into this type of instruction I have
time you use times used my nurse who at
that time had a four-year degree plus a
masters right and had a very good
understanding and had training in that
area but it's a rare find to find a
nurse like that for a school or even a
counselor so yeah and I think
um after we had a presenter the other
day I mean a lot of our schools in the
North Country actually required all of
our staff to be trained in youth mental
health first grade first aid so that the
regular ed teacher would know those
signs to be able to seek out assistance
but anyway
further discussion represent cordelli
thank you Mr chairman
um the fiscal note says that districts
might experience new cost in purchasing
curriculum we've had several bills
um communism civil rights Etc that were
not passed because we don't get involved
in curriculum but here we're getting
involved in curriculum but are we
getting involved with the curriculum
because
um of the name of the subject matter
um I I think I think we need some
consistency here on the committee
further discussion
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair so so to that to that point
representative cordelli I mean this is a
modification of an existing statute
that's specifically directed towards
health education physical education and
I think it's in a part of the law where
um where it's somewhat by what is it
called is is this the one that's under
studies yes yeah so and it's an area
that that I think the um
um the legislative budget assistant has
suggested could could actually be be
worked on a little bit more you know
right now I think it it is it's um you
know generally focused in um in the
wellness area and um and
so I'm I'm
not you know again I'm not I'm not
suggesting an ought to pass it at this
point very excited to see 151
um make it over here however I still
think it I think it's still in committee
um in the Senate come on docket
um
and uh and this gives us you know at
least a vehicle that I think could be um
you know you know could be used should
for whatever reason that stall out
somewhere yeah
further discussion represent cordiallo
so representative cascadden had just
mentioned about
um training teachers and
youth mental health I don't know is that
and and to me that's
what we should be doing I don't believe
a class of curriculum
for the students if the overall issue is
to
um help with the Mental Health crisis I
believe teachers should be more
aware of the students and and exhibiting
symptoms of mental illness
so I am concerned about the class
teaching
um I just wanted to get that out there
that I think I appreciate
this the issue and that this is the
problem the mental health issue it's a
me it's a matter of how do we address it
and I believe it's more about having the
teachers better trained
further discussion representative
cascadden
um just to add I I don't see this as a
curriculum I wouldn't want to buy a
curriculum in this field that's not our
expertise
for sure
um so I don't see it as a a curriculum
needed here
um and it certainly doesn't fall into
the criteria of what's required in
adequate education
further discussion
everybody's back uh
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll we are dealing with
uh
hb505 the emotional floor is itl
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes
representative Melville yes
representative Peter now
yes representative Court yellow yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Lane no
representative moon now no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox nope
representative Hall no Representative
alboni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no chairman Ladd
yes
10 years 10 days
Sarah motion representative uh miler yes
I'd move to retain this bill
the motion to retain
Ed by representative Damon
represent Miler makes the Motions
representative Damon second it
representative Myler I just love his
book go to vote reps and Damon
further discussion
the motion is to retain this bill
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher no
representative dry no
representative McDonnell
no
representative Noble
representative pedernal
no
representative course yellow no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Lane yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
Paul yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman that yes
14 years six Nays
this bill will be retained
next bill down is
I'm I'm going to jump over 539 right now
uh going on down here to six
uh
yeah a3627
uh 627 is a bill that's dealing with
establishing a teacher candidate loan
forgiveness program
no wait a minute no no no excuse me we
did that
I gotta jump back up higher relative
local education Improvement plans and
disparities in education I think I got
it right there
um representative motion
and move retain
is there a second okay
motion made by representative leckers to
retain second by representative Ford
Jefferson Lexus
you think this is something that the
committee as a whole needs to work on
um
there seems to be agreement in needing
accountability but there seems to be
disagreement in how it's done I had
hoped that by putting in
the wording from the Democrat Bill last
year that there would be more support
um apparently that is not the case so I
would like to work on this
actually work on this and have
subcommittees and whatever and see if we
can as a committee come up with
something that we all agree is
appropriate accountability
further discussion from the second
no okay
open to the committee for a discussion
not seeing any uh Madam clerk would you
please call the roll
the motion is to retain 627.
thanks chairman cordelli yes
representative yes representative Ford
yes representative elcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonnell yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative courts yellow yes
representative Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Lane yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes 18 years two Nays
okay
two
next field we have on the dock here is
hb514 relative no yeah relative
dissemination of obscene material by
schools and institutions of Higher
Learning
514 thank you
thank you
instead of consent
uh no that's a retain oh I'm sorry yeah
it's okay getting in the afternoon time
here
but once we're talking on five
one four
okay
representative cordelli is recognized
for a motion and I thank you Mr chairman
I move out to pass
is there a second
represent Belcher seconds at
representing cordelli
uh thank you
um
uh I think everyone I've talked to
um when they hear that uh
um K-12 schools are exempt under our
obscenity laws are shocked
um
this bill removes K-12
schools from that exemption list higher
education remains
I think we had a lot of testimony about
things that have been found by parents
in our schools
there needs to be a process where
parents can object to that
um
some of the examples that were brought
forward were quite uh shocking both in
terms of printed materials and in terms
of information found on a particular
Library app that is made available in
many of our schools on school property
I I think that this is an issue not just
in New Hampshire but Nationwide and I
think that um
removing K-12 from the exemption will
help move things in a better direction
for our children and our families in New
Hampshire
further discussion representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair uh I would
just add to that that the nature of the
materials that we're talking about I've
seen quite a bit of it myself is uh
unpleasant to look at it's the sort of
material that you will not find in most
in most search engines on the internet
unless you turn off the safe filter
this is the kind of stuff we're getting
into
um I have had I cannot tell you how many
complaints from parents that this kind
of material is accessible
um I have had conversations with
librarians
um some of them cannot believe that this
material is allowed to be accessible in
schools
um I am strongly for this Bill thank you
further discussion from the committee
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair I was speaking the other day with
a concerned parent from Dover and they
were telling me that a member at their
school board or their friend they posted
pictures of a children's book online to
a Facebook group in Dover and Facebook
took the photos down because they were
obscene
and I don't understand why this is even
a question why this should be in our
schools passing this bill would give
rights to parents to if they found
something obscene a measure and a course
of action for them to take to protect
their children it just seems obvious and
I support this bill wholeheartedly
further discussion
uh represent Cascade and then we'll come
over to the second
thank you Mr chair
I think you heard testimony I mean there
is an ideology going across the country
to
quote banned books and I know this is
not supposedly what this is
but I think by passing such a rule for
public schools K to 12 you're infringing
on my rights for my kids to learn
resilience and to be exposed to good
literature I think as a parent if I
didn't like something your local school
board has a policy ige or somewhere in
the eyes
that allows you to object to that
material and then stop your child from
participating in that piece of material
you also are your child's first teacher
to teach them what's good internet use
and what's bad internet use
I'm getting sick and tired of always
dumping on the public schools because
they don't do this that and the other
thing but yet
the support is not there to do
everything
I mean we're expected to be social
service agencies mental health clinics
vaccine you name it
but yet anything that's done to support
kids in the General Public
is never good enough well let me tell
you somebody said it the other day New
Hampshire public schools are in the top
five in the country
and we have rigorous standards in our
public schools and our kids are
successful for the most part I don't
care what school you're going to go to
private home school you're always going
to have a gamut of high Achievers and
low achievers
and public schools are designed to try
to meet the needs of the General Public
sometimes it's the extremes sometimes
it's not
but we are dealing with kids here and we
have to juggle all kinds of things to
try to meet their needs
so I cannot support this type of a bill
that's going to satisfy a handful of
parents who don't like a certain book
then be a parent and say no my kid is
not going to participate in that
and follow the school board policy on
how a parent should object because they
have that right your child does not have
to read that book you have that parent
right but you don't have the right for
the 50 other kids
that are going to learn something about
resilience and society as a whole so
that as adults they can make critical
decisions and be productive citizens
sorry that's it okay uh represent
electus
and look at that material I still cannot
get those pictures out of my mind and I
cannot believe that we want
our young children to be looking at
those pictures which happens before the
parent even finds out about it the harm
is done and I know when I went to school
the library invented the school
librarian vetted everything and we had
sections that were age appropriate we're
not talking about banning books we're
talking about having age-appropriate
material and some of that absolutely
disgusting obscene
um
pictures that were in those books that
are in elementary schools is is
I almost despair of our culture at this
point if this is considered okay
to you know and you can't you can't wipe
those pictures out of your mind
it just I'm appalled at any rate that's
my comment
going down here to represent Damon then
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
the research clearly shows that the
majority of book titles that are
targeted for Banning
are by or about people or not Caucasian
skin color or are lgbtq
I don't think this is a book a bill
about protecting our children
I think it's a book about by a bill
about bias and I'm vigorously opposed to
it
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just want to make a
quick point that I think
um is incredibly important here
this this bill is not actually crafting
a new law
it's just making a minor modification to
a law that's already on the books and
the point of me bringing that up is
right now
if a person were to approach a child on
a playground and show them the pictures
in one of these books the police would
come up put them in handcuffs and take
them to jail because that's already this
that's already the law because it's
obscene material and it's being pushed
on kids what we're saying here is that
we need to remove the exemption
that exists for whatever reason in K
through 12. it doesn't apply to colleges
they have full academic freedom
this is already a law we're just
removing the exemption for K to 12.
further discussion represent
I don't know
thank you
um
one of the things that surprised me the
most
is that I've been approached by parents
who
really want to protect their kids they
may have gone to the school about some
of this material the material is
available not necessarily just in the
classroom or part of the curriculum it's
in the library so I'm not quite sure how
you would opt out would you send a list
of books that you didn't want your child
to check out and how would a librarian
possibly be able to keep track of the
number of books that I may or may not
want my child to read I think that's
unbelievably burdensome and
I think that this bill gives those
parents who feel like they've gone to
the school gone to the school board
taken the proper channels and still not
been heard
to
have a law that has some teeth in it
that they can utilize so they don't feel
powerless anymore about when it comes to
protecting their children
thank you representative uh Noble
uh we do have a policy in place in
Bedford for a parent to go through the
process of removing a book and we had a
mom that did this uh last year
um
it didn't result in the book being
removed but she was trying to let other
parents know what was happening in their
school libraries by writing letters to
the editor in our local paper
and she was taking direct quotes from
the books and
um
the paper told her that they could no
longer publish her letters unless she
were to summarize and not use a direct
quote because it was too graphic so I
don't understand
why something like this is appropriate
in K through 12 and it's not appropriate
for adults to read in their local paper
foreign
thank you uh
a couple of things I'm not sure what
ideology is at work
um with my submission of this bill
um the intent as we heard we have to
support kids well that's that's the
intent of this bill I didn't put this
bill in in relation to any bias and I
resent that implication that there was a
bias involved in submitting this bill
um in terms of
parents objections
their apps on school property on
Chromebooks issued by the school
obscene materials on that that's being
handed out to kids by schools how the
parents is the parent going to go
through the entire app looking for
something looking for pictures
um uh I've heard from a parent
um there is a
um an objectional book in their opinion
um related to
homosexuality and it has a link so the
student can email the author of the book
we're putting students in touch with
someone who might not have their best
interest at heart how can we do that
this is an attempt
to as was stated remove the exemption
for K-12 education to protect our kids
not it's not about banning books it's
about protecting our kids thank you
representative luno
thank you Mr chip what was the um the
book that was that the parent that the
parent was trying to uh pull from
Bedford
oh gosh
um
there was a fee there was a few and I I
don't know if I can say it specifically
like was it nickel and dimed no no no no
that's what I saw pulled up in Bedford
New Hampshire that happened many years
ago okay so parents are trying to pull
books off shelves and like I'm not sure
exactly which one it was so I don't want
to put it out there I mean it I could
put it could have been Lawn Boy because
I know that that had come up at one
point yeah nickel and dimed is
yeah that is not the one that I'm
talking about right that was that was
tried on the Bedford policy yes many
years ago yes thank you
yes I just want to add one more thing to
my story
um the the mom that went through this
process they ended up pulling their kids
out of the public school
so I think
this really creates a trust problem
which is already an issue with Public
Schools right now with parents and I
just think that this erodes it even
further the more people learn about
what's in the in the kids Library
woodcock
thank you chairman
um
I'd agree with many of the things that
that uh Dr Cascade indicated earlier
when I said we'll go over the fact that
parents can have the option to pull out
but parents can tell the library and
I'll put it out and the parents
responsibility for what their children
are doing they could parents could train
children to be clear what they can or
cannot read I won't mention that but
what I will mentioned is uh part three
and part four having been in that
capacity uh on page two they said the
school principal or his designee shall
determine what material is subject to
complaint if it's harmful to minus the
school principal shall determine uh it
should be removed or restricted
why should I have the ability when in
that capacity to tell one parent what's
good for one not go to the other
I think this I think that I I do think
there's a lot more in this bill than
just uh the the concern about
pornographic materials that shouldn't be
in children's hands I have no problem
with photography Heroes not being should
of hands absolutely all right and I I
personally didn't look at the picture
that was passed up the other day but
that being said I have a real concern
about one person the school principal
they're going to decide what's good and
what's bad
and that's the way this is written under
the new section of the law on the stops
over in line 24 on page one so I think
this this bill has has a host of things
that one parent shouldn't decide and one
school principal surely shouldn't decide
and as I asked at the hearing the other
day from the the library specialist
about if it was banned in plasto and
it's okay in Pittsburgh you abandoned
Bedford and okay in Conway there this is
this is a a way out a way out of
fairness to the state and I I don't
think we should let any one person
decide what is what is fair for students
uh in particular the building principle
having sat in that chair
thank you
further discussion represent Allison oh
thank you Mr chair uh simply support uh
Representatives kiss haddon's position
that uh as a parent I have the right to
determine what my child learns in school
what books they use and as far as I know
most school districts have a process in
which you can do that what I object to
you is someone else telling me what my
kids can and cannot read
you have that right for your own kid you
do not have that right for my kid and
for everyone else is there I will also
simply just note the definition of
obesity from Justice Potter which is I
know it when I see it
and I I frankly I I do not want to have
our policies at the mercy of a whole
group of people who or a single person
who looks at something which may be
innocuous to everyone else but they
think it's obscene and that becomes the
basis for their complaint uh that that's
a real slippery slope when we get to
that point
thank you
representative
represent dry
thank you Mr chairman
yeah I'd like to just expand on
representative woodcock's comments after
the school principal or designee has a
decision regardless of which way it goes
there's a response for a repeal an
appeal that goes to the school board and
if there is still a response from uh if
a school board decision is not
acceptable either party can go to the
Department of Education so it's not just
one person's decision yes at one point
it is but then there is a large appeal
process and I just would ask you to look
at the RSA 650 the about about obscene
matter and just look at the definition
of obscene matter I mean it is almost
you will know it when you see it because
it is explicitly uh described there and
I think if you look at that definition
you would agree that there would
probably you would want if you were a
parent not just your child to not be
able to have access to it but really to
keep it out of other children's hands
because it would have been ruled obscene
Belcher just to speak to a couple points
I've heard
um I don't think anybody's suggesting
removing content from public libraries
here nobody's suggesting you can't go on
Amazon and buy a book or get a Kindle
e-reader for your home we're talking
about what's available to children in
general in public schools and I think
public important is important here
because public is another name for a
school that is run with government money
using government employees in government
just to be very clear this is scotus
opinion government does not have free
speech the people have free speech the
people are free to limit the
government's speech including obscene
materials
they may not limit each other's speech
they have no right to come into your
home
but they do have a right to regulate
their own government because this is a
government of buy and for the people
further discussion representative
McDonald thank you thank you Mr chair
I'd like to correct the record by first
saying no one here is Banning books this
bill does not ban books the intention of
this is not to ban books I can't
underscore that enough the intention is
simply to make things grade level
appropriate
and furthermore since I am certain that
this is not Banning books we
collectively can be asserting that the
intention of this bill is not to
discriminate against any ethnic or
racial group as representative daming
noted might be the case because we are
not Banning books of any racial or
ethnic group because we're not Banning
books it's that simple thank you
represent miler
thank you Mr chair
HP 514 is a very slippery slope
if it's not this now it would be that
then
it's in the eye of the beholder
no one I would assume I can pretty sure
say that in this body right here nobody
wants a child to be harmed by a
particular book or a particular picture
but I think it does
it is incumbent upon the parents
to deal with the school district and
it's a local decision on the school
district to make a decision on which
book is age appropriate Etc
I mean those those policies are already
in place
and I'll speak personally about a book
that was mentioned just a minute ago
this goes back to Slippery Slope
question I've read The Lawn Boy
I made sure my grandkids read the long
boy
we talked about the concepts in the Lawn
Boy as a teaching moment
now that was fine for me
but for some other parent they may not
want their child to read the long boy
and that's perfectly okay my point is
is that we cannot be we cannot make
decisions
on something this important for for kids
and for parents in dealing with their
children on what they're going to learn
and how they're going to learn it and I
think this goes Way Beyond what's needed
at this point in time because I think
there are policies already in place
there are due process issues that are
already in school districts where
parents can challenge the uh the
Brokenness of a particular article Etc I
don't do not think that this is
necessary I think it goes Way Beyond
what we have right now thank you
further discussion
I haven't weighed in on anything at this
point in time but I I do have a couple
more like technical type questions here
uh I'd like to look at line six
no recognized or established institution
in the University system or the
community college system of New
Hampshire
and I know I do know for a fact that we
have certain classes taught at the
University Systems in the area of
Criminal Justice
and cyber security
which these types of obscene materials
are used as you know as used in the
instructional teaching process
but is it possible the way this bill is
written now that this will be seen as an
obscene matter
and the there could be a possible
hearing as a result of using these
things in a classroom represent Lucas
that line that you're talking about no
recognized or established institution in
the united University system or
chromology system Museum public library
or governmental agency
Etc shall be arrested charged or
indicted for any violation of a
provision of this chapter they're being
Exempted from this chapter so no we are
not going to be doing anything to them
read that sentence all it says until
such time read the rest of it till such
time as the material involved has been
first been the subject as an adversary
hearing where in such institution or
person is made a defendant and after
such material is declared by the court
to be obscene matter such institution or
person continues to engage in the
contact conduct prohibited by this
chapter the sole issue with the hearing
shall be whether and that gets then
covered under no the last sentence the
sole issue at the hearing shall be
whether the material is obscene material
that's what I said because that comes
under title
62. yeah represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair actually if if instead of looking
at that you look at lines one and the
following line
justifile justifiable and non-commercial
private dissemination if you were then
to go over to RSA 6 650 uh colon 4 and
read that you'll find that the modified
sentence here is actually a affirmative
defense against any sort of hearings or
prosecution under this article so that
any higher education is absolutely
Exempted
is what is is totally Exempted from this
and look at the next section
you you actually have to go over to 650
colon 4 to read how the next sentence
modifies that one sentence in that in
that law under justifiable affirmative
uh defense
It also says that the it may only be
initiated by the County Attorney the
County Attorney General the Department
of Health and Human Services or the
Department of Education so it's not some
parent or student or whatever
and it's covered all by the criminal
code
well that still Rings a concern to me
um
the other part that I have a concern on
is down on lines 29 and 30.
complaints submitted by parents are
permanent Guardians
in Statue what's the difference between
a permanent guardian and a guardian or
is a child placed in Foster families
able to make a complaint
they're not able to make a complaint but
they're the ones that are supervising
and taking care of that child
these are some of the things that just
you know I had written down in pencil
here so I don't have this with me today
so it's it's nothing I've written right
now I've had those concerns about that
language is it
is there an issue associated with our
trying to narrow it down to that point
submitted by it by parents
well that
I don't know I'm not an attorney I can't
answer that uh or permanent Guardians
what's the difference between the person
has a guardian or a custodian or
custody
perhaps I'm
prettily thank you
um that was taken from elsewhere instead
a statute parents of permanent Guardians
and the intent there was to restrict it
um so that someone walking off the
street wouldn't be coming into file a
complaint about about something I wanted
someone who has a child in in the school
that was the purpose there and in
section two
that the current verbiage is no
recognized established School Museum Etc
that's current law
um I changed School
so that K-12 was no longer Exempted and
just the institutions and the university
system the community college system were
Exempted
so I you'll see school is crossed out
but that's what is in current language
now
um
uh I
I'm not sure why
K-12 education should be exempt from our
obscenity laws that's the basic question
to me
uh maybe
um you know should uh you know public
libraries we talked about public
libraries they're
um they're exempt so if you want to take
out whatever book you can put in a
request in a library alone if you want
um
you know acting drama you know museums
it's it's all exempt
um but I don't think that K-12 education
should be exempt from our obscenity loss
and that's the basic um argument for me
further discussion
representative Ford
I'd like to add
another dimension to the discussion
and I think you might want to consider
you've got to use your red yeah I think
you might want to consider making a
distinction when you're talking about
I've seen about visual images as opposed
to written documentation
such as the novel which might by some be
considered obscene
but if you make that novel in and of
itself obscene
and I stopped by my girlfriend's house
and I have my books from college there
and her little brother reads it or plays
with it or looks at it suddenly I am a
child abuser
by your definition
well I'm at it's it's worth considering
because her parents are going to be on
my case and they're not going to miss
words
Preston Belcher if I might clarify just
to that point there is something of a
point there but it has nothing to do
with this bill because this bill is only
looking to exempt uh K-12 schools it
would not exempt individuals individuals
are already not exempt they would be
theoretically under this law although I
believe it requires an affirmative act
not an act of negligence allowing a
child to get to something it has to be
done on purpose
yeah
so I'll ask this question I do know of a
school
that doesn't have a library internally
they use the public library across the
street
and Library classes are constantly going
back and forth for instruction from the
public school librarian
this bill right here would make it
acceptable to have materials in a public
library but that the public library is
also now a school library
so how how do we correct that issue
represent Belcher if I may speak to that
again uh thank you Mr chair so again the
the because we're dealing with something
that falls under an element of criminal
law there is an element what's called
men's Ria or Criminal Intent is going to
be involved in this so it wouldn't be a
matter of you walked across the street
with your classroom and a student
discovers a book it would have to be you
would have to put that book in the
child's hand or assign it to them in
order for something like this to apply
[Music]
sorry to your point so if you're a
librarian and you're the child brings a
book and you're checking it out
um isn't she putting the book in the
child's hand at that point
thank you Mr chair I'll speak to that um
were you referencing public libraries
because they're already Exempted no just
energy I'm just referring to the actions
so if the librarian is placing the book
If the child brings a book and the title
takes it out is that from what you're
saying is that could be a crime
if we're talking about a public library
not a school library public libraries
are Exempted from the law and this this
bill does not take them off that
exemption list so they would remain
Exempted this only applies to school
libraries you can make the case that a
teacher going over to a public library
with her school or with her students and
placing a public library book into the
hands of one of their students that
violates the obscenity law would not be
exempt but the public library itself is
accepted
can say that this situation is occurring
in one of the schools in my district
where the teachers walk over across the
street to the public library
and the public librarian along with the
teacher or teacher assist pair that goes
with them
helped sign these books out
so
um and being a public library which is
accepted they're going to probably come
across obscene material
representative cascaden thank you just
to give another example I was a
superintendent for the lime school
district and the person who did the
library media for the students K to
eight was the public librarian in the
library for the school was the public
library across the street and she taught
the classes so how do you distinguish
between public and private public and
school because they had a dual role
if we're going to get down into the
weeds like that would it be possible for
the parent to just say
I think the books in the public library
are obscene therefore my child cannot
participate in that class going over to
the library I mean so so that's a moot
point then
you know
represent Woodcock thank you I can't
keep up with the computer though Belcher
over there I still have my flip phone
but
um it does say in their first amendment
uh book Banning a definition I wanted to
keep my thought I was thought book
Banning I'm thinking if you take a book
out of the library then you're Banning
it but I must be wrong book Banning a
form of censorship occurs when private
individuals government officials or
organizations remove books from
libraries School reading lists or
bookstore shells because they objective
the consent idea of the theme so that's
it sounds like book bang censorship to
me from the First Amendment encyclopedia
I'm trying to learn
representative McDonald wow you made my
shot my hand excuse me you made mine and
shoot up very fast representative
woodcock
to your point I would just like to
correct you on your use of the First
Amendment I'm assuming you're talking
about the United States Constitution
according the First Amendment uh
definition as presented
that's all
according First Amendment so I believe
representative Belcher was the one who
noted earlier that the freedom of speech
in the first amendment applies to the
people and not to the government again
Public Schools or government entities so
they would already be exempt from those
thank you
thank you representative
further discussion representative luno
do you have something
he has a laptop he's quick on my phone
actually Mr chair I I do have something
and at the risk of
um
sounding really sort of out of water on
on 650 which is not an area that I think
this committee spends much time in it's
probably not in our books either
right fair enough
650 is an area we spend a whole lot of
time in
um but with the with the change
on line six and elsewhere How would how
would then this not apply to let's say
Dartmouth College
let's just say Dartmouth College
no um well for one thing Dartmouth
College was established before the state
was established and so
um Dartmouth is not beholding to much of
what we do in terms of in terms of
um
um degree granting Authority but yeah
but um you know when yeah and so yeah I
mean any any of our private colleges but
you know in looking at 650 and again I
don't have a lot of experience with it
it starts with definition
it then talks about offenses a guilty a
person is guilty of a misdemeanor if he
commits obscenity when talks about this
doesn't say that a person employed at a
government you know
um institution doesn't say that the
first use of the word government is in
is in section 650 colon 4 uh where it
says justifiable and non-commercial
private uh dissemination so
non-commercial private
um and it talks about
it just uses the word governmental there
but it's
not used anywhere else until you get to
650 colon six
and the word governmental agency I don't
think applies to all of the other
descriptors
um
in there and so when you want when you
take out school and you replace it with
University system and Community College
system I think basically your your your
saying it now applies to all schools
that are not part of the University
system or community college system
I mean am I missing something
representative cordelli uh
uh thank you in section one
um under 654 uh institutions of persons
having a scientific educational is
crossed out and higher education is
substituted as six 650 colon for Roman
one
so higher education is substituted for
education so that we're exempting K-12
but higher education remains um exempt
on line three no line three of the bill
it's chairman may I yeah help on this
one I think it actually is going to make
more sense to you if you go to the
actual RSA 650 colon 4 and if you go
there what you will see is it says
justifiable and non-commercial private
dissemination isn't a it is an
affirmative defense to prosecution under
this chapter that dissemination was
restricted to the following it then has
line one so it doesn't say all that in
the current bill you're looking at right
but it modifies line one under that
section and that's where that exemption
uh comes from so it's it's basically the
same mistake I made earlier today
he seems good defense approximation
but you're still
yeah you're still going through
your exempt from your exempt from
process your exempt from prosecution
further discussion
representative I just wanna I've been
thinking about this and about what you
said about this whole situation where
the public library or the public school
kids are going over to the public
library and as you know I work in a
public library and I'm thinking we are
experiencing similar problems where
people are objecting to obscene books in
our collection and
fortunately those books are kept in the
adult section uh
so I would hope that if a public school
is using the public library for their
kids to go over that they would uh only
let the students be in the children's
room where those materials generally are
not kept I just want to get that out
there because I'm thinking this whole
time about it I don't know how okay to
12. okay so that's the problem with
public library because anybody can go
and access yeah but anybody can access
you go into a public library and you can
do your best to kind of separate the
kids stuff from the adult stuff but you
know the kids are free to go wander up
to the adult section where there are
some very questionable books so
um I just want to get that out there
just from my experience
that's true
is there any further discussion on this
bill at this point in time Mr chair I'd
ask for a three-minute caucus please you
may
Seth fine with you
and uh let's make it a little bit longer
in case people have to make a you know
an entry somewhere else
so make it about 10 minutes please
ER
February 27th that's over vacation yeah
it's like Tuesday
um
thank you
bothered me because no one could have
spoken up eventually you feel
uncomfortable by the people who are
insisting that they use this thing yeah
whatever gender they claim to be and yet
they have genitalia that men should
argue the other way and I think somehow
we need to show as much respect for the
other kids as for those who are
[Music]
some kids are scared
I'll tell you we even if we go
marginal recommendation this is not
going to pass honestly no no I don't
think it's gonna it's not shouted down
before it's even well if there's there's
enough people to have some freaking
brains but
thank you
consideration
oh well I've got to go myself right now
thank you very much art
all right what did you gather you got it
I know that's right yeah
some people have a five gallon tank some
people have one young tank and sometimes
you have conditions that make this
shrink further than that
just like the old saying my mother used
to do you know when we're driving yeah
yeah she put the hose through the
floorboards and put a funnel on it and
that voice we were required to use that
and just keep them wide enough just keep
our going right she wouldn't stop yeah
she'd buy because one bottle of Orange
Crush yeah
foreign
thank you
unless there is
something new that hasn't been discussed
or presented I'd like to go right into
the taking action on the Motions on the
floor is there any further discussion on
Madam clerk would you please repeat the
motion that we're acting on right now on
HP 514
ought to pass
you're welcome
so that is the motion the the relative
to the dissemination obscene materials
by schools and institutions Higher
Learning ma'am clerk would you please
call the roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative Noble yes representative
yes representative cortielo yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Lane no Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox no representative Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascaden no representative Damon no
chairman left yes
10 years 10 days
yes represent Miler I moved to itl this
month is there a second oh second
motion made by representative Miler
second by represent Woodcock uh itl is
that motion
further discussion from the maker none
thank you second
on to the motion map I'll speak to you
for me I'll speak to it okay represent
Balboni okay
uh we had a lot of discussion and I'm
just going to summarize a few points of
it
um one is that this bill essentially is
a book ban
parents in New Hampshire already have
the right to review materials and opt
their child out of anything that they
find objectionable for school district
policies and I have one in front of me
right here which is exactly the opt-out
hang on sorry
this is the opt-out policy it's uh
policy kec and it references public
concerns and complaints about
instructional resources
um and it's it goes in a very uh detail
about what that process is and what the
appeal process is so this policy is
already in place in most school
districts and that's a majority of the
bill just to continue on I feel uh I
think that this bill
is putting in the hands of other parents
what what other parents kids can do and
can't do I find that also there's a lot
of definitions in here are that are kind
of subjective who determines what's
objectionable what's obscene and what's
age-appropriate because what's what that
means to me as a parent might be
different than what it means to a
different parent
um and students should have a wide
access to materials and school Personnel
are trained to review materials selected
for their schools and their number of
policies in place that specifically
address how school districts select the
books and materials for their school
districts
um so I feel very strong that this bill
should igl
further discussion representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair just very
briefly
children are experiencing moral injury
they're being shown porn
in schools
this is our chance to put it into that
any further discussion Madam clerk would
you please call the rule
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative blackis no representative
Ford
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pedernal no Representative cortiello no
representative Myler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Lane yes
representative Luna yes represented
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon no
sorry yes
yes
chairman Ladd no
10 years 10 days
okay who's gonna make uh okay
and the represent cordelli the other
okay sure why not
okay we have two bills we're going to do
and these are the bills that I think we
should be able to scoot right through
seeing you there at least a little while
ago there was mutual agreement on
um
uh 634 uh relative to the students
participation in religious instruction
to satisfy effective curriculum
requirements I'll look uh look to
represent pettinell for a motion
I move itl on House Bill 634. is there a
second second
motion made by representative now second
by second by representative Ford uh the
making a motion is there any discussion
I certainly hope not
good represent Ford nothing further
further discussion of the committee
ma'am clerk would you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
yes representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Lane yes
representative Bruno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni
yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman yes 28
zero news consent yes thank you
uh next next bill which we have is
604 this act is relative to reading
specialists
representing Cordelia recognized for
emotion uh thank you Mr chairman I'd
like to move I uh ought to pass
is there a second
second represent four seconds
representative cordelli are you hearing
uh discuss
uh just briefly
um the current statute just allows for
contracted services for a reading
specialist the bill allows for the
Employments of a staff member
is there a further discussion from the
maker II
no nope
further discussion from the committee
and clerk would you please call the rule
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative elcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble
yes representative pedernal yes
representative yes representative Myler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner oh sorry Mushi uh
uh representative Lane
yes by both names
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 years
[Music]
thank you with that I think we ought to
call quits for today
um we'll take up the remaining bills and
when they're posted next on the in the
calendar
we have no meetings tomorrow and have no
meetings on Monday Monday being a
holiday so we have four days ahead of us
to rest up
regain ourselves we will be meeting on
the 21st
for for hearings here uh in this room we
will most likely have session on the
22nd and 23rd
we will meet here on the 24th for
further hearings
and hopefully we can finish earrings on
all the bills which we've had in
education by the break
and then come back after the break and
start executing the remaining bills
which we have not exact
but we're just all going to have to
really get on task during those you know
the weeks of the days in March to do
that I think we can do it we're just
going to be a little bit quicker with
some of our exec sessions here
the reports today
are needed
actually we've gone by the due date
already here
but I don't want to go so far that you
forget to do the report and that's
happened many times before
and I've ended up having to write a lot
of reports and that I don't care to do
so let's see we're out on Monday I think
when you
come back on I'd like to have them if we
can
by by sometime at the latest on Monday
so that means you have to email them to
me you got the email using the uh
template that we have for reporting
please that makes it a lot easier if you
don't have the template let me know and
we'll email you another attachment with
the template there to get your your
reports completed
on 71 you know we we we're going to get
a whole doe and do a little bit more
understanding where we are on that
that's that's on hold there's we we
didn't conclude that
um
and no reports on retain
where there is no recommendation yes
both sides have to write the reports
so thank you everybody have a good four
days
hopefully have some spring-like weather
no I'm today yeah
I haven't looked at it yet
remember if anybody's going to be absent
everybody listen up please
we we have an opportunity to get some of
this exacting done before we go out and
break on the 24th because that could put
probably into that that calendar where
we're going to be hearing some things
the opportunity to accept some of the
bills we had on our platter today and
try to get some of that washed out other
than the ones which we need more
information on we won't go that route
but we didn't get to
um 563 we didn't get the 394 to 632 and
we're going to be holding off on on the
two building Improvement our building
eight uh one for the building a process
the other for the charter school
building eight we held off in that other
than that those are the ones I really
want to take care of and we could also
uh if we have some bills we want to exec
on Friday of that day we could exec the
bills which we are hearing on that day
so be aware that we we will most likely
have an exact session on the 24th if
you're going to be absent please let
either mail or myself know that
thank you